Did Joe Rogan Association podcast is brought the association.
I was thinking my brain is crossing signals right now cause I was thinking of a
radical feminist associations and it got a got brought up.
Sometimes I'm talking about something and if I'm done,
I've done it too many times.
Like the introduction to the podcast,
I go on full on autopilot so I don't really know what the fuck is coming out of
my mouth until it comes out.
And then my brain goes,
wait,
what?
So I went on full auto pilot there.
I fucked it up.
The chew real can podcast is brought to,
this episode is actually brought to you by a guest sponsor,
which is audible.com and if you've ever gone audible.com if you're read the
audio books,
it's the shit.
It's a really amazing website.
If you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
they uh,
I don't know.
What do they do?
They hook you up with something,
download a free.
Okay,
you can try it free for 30 days.
That's what it is.
And believe me,
if you're a person who commutes especially,
I think one of the things,
one of the reasons why I was really into doing this is I think a lot of the
people that listen to this podcast listen to it while they're commuting or you
listened to it when you're at the gym where you listen to it when you're on a
plane and what I consider places where you're stuck somewhere or you would like
something to entertain you.
And uh,
it's a very,
it's kind of a new,
really an uncaptured form of entertainment.
I mean,
for the longest time all we had was like radio and cds in the cars,
but with,
with podcasts and audio books,
man,
sometimes I don't want to park.
If I got a bad ass audio book on and I'm really into it,
I don't want to fucking park my car.
I would shut my phone off and I'll listen to a good story.
And um,
uh,
so audible,
if you try it free for 30 days,
I guarantee you're going to like it.
They have a tremendous selection of fiction and nonfiction and the one that I'm
going to recommend they wanted me to recommend.
One is the war of art by a guy named Steven Pressfield.
And uh,
it's a fucking amazing book that really changed my life and made me really
understand like the roadblocks to being creative and what,
what people do sort of set themselves up for failure.
They create little traps and problems in their creative life.
And this book really outlines that better than anything I've ever written.
And uh,
it's just,
uh,
to me like one of the most inspirational books that I've ever,
that I've ever read.
I haven't listened to the audio version of it,
but I'm sure it's good.
All,
all the audible ones are the shit.
It's a,
it's a really great website.
So check it out.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com if you go to [inaudible] dot
com now you'll see that we have hemp force protein powder in which is fucking
sensational.
Does not make you fart in nearly as much as whey protein.
It's really easy to digest.
It's got Maca and raw cocoa in it,
and the MCCA is,
is good for your endocrine system.
It's supposed to make your dick hard,
allegedly.
It's never worked for me.
I've never eaten Mac and bill fuck bitches.
But that's one of the things it's supposed to do.
It's supposed to increase your libido.
Uh,
and that raw cocoa is actually a very strong antioxidant and it's sweetened with
Stevia.
So it only has one gram of sugar per serving.
So it's very low sugar and it tastes fucking fantastic and it's really good for
you.
It's called hemp force protein powder and a,
we also have kettle bells and battle ropes in,
along with all the nootropics that we push every week,
like Alpha brain,
which I take before every podcast.
That's why I talk so much bit.
So what do you mix with this?
This hemp stuff just makes it with ice or do you mix it with almond milk?
I'll use coconut water and a banana.
That's what I use.
And it's easy.
And the vitamin test?
Yeah,
it's so easy to digest.
It's like [inaudible] like there's,
I don't feel like I even ate something.
Like I'm not hungry,
but I don't feel like I need something.
It's super easy.
Whereas I love like muscle milk and there's a bunch of like protein powders.
It tastes awesome.
They like taste like,
like treats like dessert.
But the shit just makes you fart like crazy.
It's all that way and sugar and your body's like,
why are you doing?
Oh,
okay.
This is a good way to go about it in a bad way to go about it.
And,
uh,
the hemp is the best way for me.
Plus he get marijuana street cred.
You know what I'm talking about?
What'd you get these muscles from?
Some looking at them shifts from weed bits.
Um,
and if you were interested in nootropics,
I s I suggest that you Google the word nootropic and find out what the fuck I
means.
Because if you're taking advice from a comedian that used to be the fear factor
host on anything I suggest you look deeper.
Uh,
nootropics are just vitamins.
They're vitamins that have been shown to have a positive positive effect on
cognitive function.
Uh,
essentially it helps your brain produce more neurotransmitters.
It's like the building blocks of nutrition that your brain needs to function at
an optimal level.
And a,
there's a lot of controversy behind the subject,
but I've been a fan of nootropics for years.
I've been taking it for years and I absolutely feel a difference when I take him
and when I don't,
as well as I feel the difference between when I eat really healthy,
when I don't,
when I have like Kale shakes for breakfast in the morning and eat clean food and
make sure I drink a lot of water,
I feel different than when I just got off a plane and I've been eating shitty
food.
It's,
it's,
it's a real obvious take care of your body,
get optimum results.
You could be swole like me and Everlast get yourself some kettlebells,
bitch,
if you're interested in the kettle bells and we got them on sale.
All different sizes,
all different packages,
battle ropes as well.
Um,
what a battle ropes son,
you got to learn.
You've got to learn about the battle ropes,
crazy ropes.
You throw around like Conan the barbarian and get one of them.
Impressive physiques.
All of it is available at [inaudible] dot com so go check it out.
O n n I t and use a code name Brogan.
You will save 10% off any and all supplements.
And uh,
we also have a 100% money back guarantee on the supplement,
especially for the first order of,
or essentially only for the first order of 30 pills.
We let you try it.
And uh,
if you don't agree,
you know,
you don't think that it's worth it,
then you don't even have to send it back in to get your money back.
And I think that's important because I don't want anybody to feel ripped off.
I think the most important thing in selling anything is the most important thing
is that you have to sell something of value and people have to appreciate it,
enjoy it.
And if you're not doing that,
if you're squeezing money out of people,
I don't want to be involved.
There's nothing that we sell that isn't something that I use and enjoy and that
I would recommend even if they didn't give me a nickel.
Just like a recommended CTO,
coconut water.
Cause it's this shit.
All right.
That's it.
Cue The music.
Everlast is here,
ladies and gentlemen.
We're going to get deep.
We're going to break it down for ourselves and for others.
[inaudible]
of America.
That squire.
Yeah.
We were talking about a feminism feminists that are angry.
It's such a Cliche,
you know,
the angry feminist cliche is a funny one.
You know,
like every man,
every man shakes his head.
It goes,
oh Jesus.
Not One of those,
you know,
it's a strange,
a strange designation roof on Twitter for you dog.
No,
we need to be Uber Fans.
Yeah,
but they need to relax.
We need to be humans.
You know,
I think people completely misunderstood.
We had a podcast the other day and you know,
it got,
I got a little shoddy.
Uh,
it was a,
it's a very important issue for me about the,
the idea of censorship and you know,
for me,
I know,
you know the whole story happened.
Yeah.
You know the toss story.
So for people didn't know the Taj Story.
Tosh he said something to a woman in the crowd,
you know,
it was just responding to like,
he's fucking around with the crowd and said something like,
wouldn't it be fun if she got raped by five people?
What it was it,
someone said you should joke about rape.
He goes on a rant about how rape,
well yeah,
what's funny about rape and like all the things that aren't funny about rape.
And she goes,
actually rape has never funny.
So he goes,
wouldn't it be funny if five guys raped her?
It's funny.
I'm sorry.
It's unfortunate and it's,
you'll like this is not the best kind of comedy.
You know,
the best kind of comedy is there's no victims.
Everybody gets out clean rape jokes 15 minutes or raped.
You look rape.
Isn't that funny dude?
It's,
it's just occasionally it's the right thing to say.
It's if it's like you have to look at comedy as an equation,
what's,
what's the 10 move there?
I'll tell you what the 10 move is.
The 10 move is,
wouldn't it be funny if somebody raped her?
It's the,
it's the,
the,
the Kale part.
Ha.
I'm a musician and I feel like you got to own your stage.
A comedian has to do it in a whole different way.
Like literally a comedian if,
if they,
if you're synced week,
I mean it's coming at you from all that.
So if you don't make that joke,
if you don't show it,
I,
okay,
here it is.
Here's why I really don't want to do it.
Fine.
Here it is.
You know,
the question of whether he had to write to or not as a stupid question.
Of course he did.
It's in that it's in the environment of standup comedy and somehow or another,
this is,
everybody has gotten so God damn over sensitive.
It wasn't till like half of the jokes in bore rat rape jokes.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Right.
It also has its dude's getting raped.
Nobody cares.
Dudes can get raped all that.
Yeah,
you could say,
I'm going to rape you to any guy.
Right.
It's pretty much nothing.
I mean it sucks if it happens,
but you gave me permission but it is not the same and it,
and we don't approach it the same so we don't understand that the same.
So I think what they're asking for,
if I understand the other side statement is that they,
they,
they want a higher degree of sensitivity from people.
And I say that they're not related because it's not about being sensitive.
It's about someone saying something absolutely preposterous for humor.
It's not about being sensitive in that in that environment and the environment
stand up.
Comedy Dad's an art form.
The only way to do it correctly is you got to go balls out.
And what he did is he went balls out.
He said,
wouldn't it be funny if you know why it's connect?
Kind of like the whole point of like that whole aristocrats joke like is like
that who can be the craziest,
stupidest,
outrageous like ridiculous dumb thing.
Who can go there that jokes a style of comedy.
I mean the,
the idea of that joke did that,
that really complete Raunchy,
like we had dice clay on the podcast yesterday that,
that over the top,
that's like a legitimate art form.
And for what if just because you don't like it,
it doesn't mean you should get so fucking shitty about other people practicing
that our farm and in when you step in and start saying things like,
a guy shouldn't have said this certain thing to one certain person in the heat
of a moment.
I think that's craziness.
You know?
I think that that's just straight fucking nonsense.
So all these people getting upset at me and then they get the wrong impression.
I'm for everybody being equal.
I am.
I'm a humanist.
I don't like women more than I like men and I don't like men more than I like
women.
I like nice people.
I like women and better than I like men.
Just for the record.
Do you?
Yeah,
there's a lot of them that are really pretty.
Look,
what I'm trying to say is we should all,
we should be humanists.
We should this idea of masculinist.
That's fucking nonsense.
You imagine if I started putting it on my Twitter profile that I was a radical
masculinist pitches would start attacking me.
They would think it'd be fine to start attacking me.
They would just go,
what do you have?
A small penis?
I'm sorry about your penis not working.
Whatever it is.
If five fucking something you,
your insecurities,
your fucking problems with your father.
I'm not here to deal with you.
They would find some reason to be mad at you.
Joe.
If he had to live with one person for the rest of your life,
everyone else died except a female or a male,
who would it be?
Which one would it be?
A bit,
dude.
Really?
Yeah.
Sorry mom.
I don't know man.
The person in the whole world,
you have to fucking be with one other person for the rest of your life.
No other people in the whole entire road.
Just a woman or a man and this is either you know George Clooney or the top of
the line female like,
well usually it doesn't matter the top of the line.
Female,
the what's matters is her personality.
Right?
For you.
If you're going to deal with a lifelong proposition,
the most important thing is that she's an easy going person you can actually get
along with.
So that would be the ideal move is someone who would,
you know,
be down for fucking
Joe.
You're supposed to say your wife.
You supposed to say that,
but that's,
that's obvious.
I think you would have to,
um,
you would have to really decide how much sex do you wanted for the rest of your
life.
Yeah.
I think that's pretty important.
So it's really all about,
you only have one person.
We don't feel like I'm going to love your wife,
my wife.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
But it's so obvious,
so obvious.
He can't say it like one of those,
well,
I love my wife,
my wife.
The best one is,
uh,
what's his face?
Um,
Groucho Marx had a talk show you,
I think it was,
you bet your life.
Uh,
and,
uh,
a guy came on and,
it's worrying if I'm Bob.
And the guy's like,
you know,
Cincinnati,
you have kids.
And he's like,
I've got six kids and the Groucho Marx,
Marx spelled wow.
When he goes,
well,
I love my wife grabbed,
she goes,
I love my cigar,
but I take it out of my mouth every now and then for back then.
That was like,
no one could believe what he said.
They were like,
what the fuck?
What did you just say?
You went crazy.
I don't show.
He was a to show where the bird with the secret word.
Groucho was such a bad motherfucker.
He was.
That dude was ahead of his time.
That dude was way ahead of his time.
Dude's did not get Groucho Marx.
He had to tone it down for those fools taped down as much.
That
kind of weird.
It was that.
Yeah,
Groucho Marx with it.
Shit.
He was a fucking smart dude,
man.
The idea that the idea that the way that you know,
I think,
not joking about anything,
it's silly.
The idea that you could tell a comedian that he can't joke about anything,
especially when you absolutely know that they didn't mean that they absolutely
don't mean that someone should get raped.
That's not what they intent is supposed to be.
What language is conveying.
It's all supposed to be what is going on in my mind.
You're pretending that you don't understand the subtleties of the conversation.
You're playing stupid so that you can get angry and I think that is fucking
maddening.
That shit drives me nuts.
They know no one really wants anybody to get raped,
so you're playing stupid.
You're pretending that it really does mean that and it's contributing to a whole
culture of people believing that.
Dammit,
bitches settled the fuck
down.
Calm down.
Dan.
Dan,
who's Dan,
this guy has said that was going to rape at the beginning of the Pi
three why is that so?
You didn't see pointing Joe at the beginning of the podcast.
I have it.
When I was on audible,
this was thing came up in this chat room.
It's like,
hi,
I'm Dan from audible here to help you.
And I start texting him and I'm sorry for what?
I said,
what did you say to him?
I said I was going to rape them.
Did you really say that?
Yeah.
Did you do that while we're doing the park test?
I feel bad cause right it.
When I did,
I was like,
man,
I'm too stone.
It was a really bad idea.
So Dan,
I did not mean it.
Yeah.
What if Dan's listening man,
and he's like,
that guy's an asshole.
Just made me feel uncomfortable.
And then we've got to really dumb argument whether know rape is a more
worse than murder.
What's worse?
Rape or murder.
The whole thing was so stupid.
What do you think?
Where's rape or murder?
Would you rather get raped or murdered?
They'll fuck outta here.
It's such,
just stupid.
Who would win if you're raping me,
I better already have been murdered.
Yeah,
no shit.
Right.
Saved to rape until after I'd been murdered.
Die Eventually.
Maybe this is how we go.
I was raped actually just the other day,
man.
I had my recent physical.
Oh,
sucks.
What was it?
A ball or an ass.
It's horrible.
Isn't it weird that they have to do have to dig in your body.
See what you got to go in and check your prostate.
Let's see how it the fuck.
See How freaky you live in which you get like,
I think it's 60 my dad said that when he turns 60 you have to get a tube in your
penis hole.
Oh,
check your penis hole.
Okay.
Remind me to check out before I'm 60 well,
I think they want to check to see if it's all swollen.
A fucked up in there.
That's why I like a lot of dudes have to go to the bathroom every 15 minutes.
Yeah,
that shit ain't good.
Can't be fun.
It can be fun.
They say that you you have to beat off though.
You could avoid a lot of that.
A lot of dudes just quit beating off.
They just tap out these people.
Who are these people not beating by the way,
that is not a scientific diagnosis.
People who like I hate when he spelled pseudo science.
I'm not saying that that's a fact,
but that is what I read on the Internet.
I'm sure that was written.
It was in a sentence.
I absorbed it and I said all right,
there you go.
They believe that one way does stop prostate problems as masturbation,
enlargement of the prostate.
Now you go.
So dudes will beat off a lot.
They don't have that problem with holding in their pee.
So if you see a guy peeing all the time it keeps getting up cause he's doing
coke man.
Come on.
Either put the sneaky pouch away or go go jerk one off.
You know
the slinky pouch man,
kind of sneak off to sneaky pouch.
Is that a flashlight?
He called him like a sneaky little pouch and cocaine.
You can go sneaky pouch and you take the homeys and you go to the bathroom and
you know it comes back a little lighter than it went in.
Now you have your own sneaky pouch in a weird thing when you,
you ever been at a party and you know this one dude who just has just enough
coke for himself.
So he's trying to sneak off and do it,
but he doesn't want anybody knowing and everybody's like,
he's this motherfucker on coke.
Like what's going on here?
They don't let it.
Joey Diaz gets so fucking mad if he finds out that you did like,
like he uh,
he uh,
I think it wa,
I don't want to say his name,
but someone that someone did it to him at his apartment and he was trying to
pretend he wasn't doing calculus.
Go in and my fucking bathroom,
you'd coming out all geeked out.
You're not offering me none.
It's a weird thing when people want to sneak off and do drug in quiet.
Yeah.
That's what I know is bad news.
Luckily I always had a little bit of that heart issue too,
so I never really got deep into evolved into any of it.
I never fucked a few times when I was really young and then it was like,
oh,
I got a problem.
Okay.
I'm probably be a good idea to stay away from coke and meth.
It seems like
everybody that that gets into it though really enjoys the shit out of it.
You know what I mean?
It must be doing something really wild while it's happening because they can't
wait to do it again.
Yeah.
Fucking terrible for you though.
I have never forget this.
I was on the,
on the highway headed back from Kelly's roast beef.
I know I've told this story before,
but I'm gonna tell it again and this is what I remember of cocaine.
There was a car that was right next to us.
The Dome light was on,
and then some people moving around in the backseat and as we're driving up to
them,
I look over and it's a girl doing coke and she looks at me and she goes,
and that to me in my mind was coke.
It was coke.
That's funny.
Like some girl is like screaming,
fuck you.
It's sticking her finger at me and I'm in the other car.
I didn't say a word.
I didn't,
I didn't respond.
I just,
I just looked at her and went,
wow,
fuck that drug
man.
Last time I did coke,
it was maybe seven years ago.
And the good part about coke is that it's just women love it.
And so like I said to her like one girl,
like,
oh,
I got some coke,
you want to go to the bathroom and do it.
But we were at this party and uh,
she brought like seven of the hottest girls and we just pretty much sat in the
bathroom.
Uh,
these girls just like fucking like going to the bathroom in front of me and
just,
and just do what we're doing.
Cope with like these seven girls.
And it was just,
they all started blowing you.
Would that be the guy would have been the good part of it?
Yeah.
That would have been a good part of the story.
Then would you be sad that you did coke and then you couldn't get it up?
No.
I like,
I've never had prompt the only,
you know what I said this the other day,
I never had a problem with ever getting a boner on any kind of drug.
I,
that's a lie.
Actually.
The,
the one time I couldn't do it was on ecstasy at the peak of ecstasy.
And do you have like a really small penis to just fires up and he at any moment
because just take a lot to load it.
Oh,
is that what it is?
It just takes one tear drop
instantly.
Remember those old John Holmes movies were home.
He couldn't get it up.
Now remember that most of the John Holmes movies who he's always dealing with
like a half rubber snake because his dick was huge.
It took a lot to get his dick hard.
And those cats were all on coke.
Like if you talked to the people like the,
there were a,
you know,
doing torn back in the day,
how's calls,
guys were all gacked out of their mind and they're trying to fuck on camera.
You know?
And it's,
if you watch like the old porn,
like I did a David tell has a show.
Dave's old man,
I've seen him.
And if you sit there and watch the old porn a lot of times too,
it had hard on problems that dude's like it would have all these hot chicks
blowing him,
sucking on his Dick and there was nothing happening like this must be for that
guy.
The most frustrating video,
like how to imagine if there was all this video of you or someone's just
sucking,
you're completely limp Dick on camera with his hot three Hutchinson's lights and
cameras and guys who stand there and you just can't get up.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Yeah.
I couldn't do it in front of all those people.
I think that would be the worst part and having just like the camera guys and
stuff,
you have to be a sociopath maybe.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That'd be rough.
Yeah.
I don't know if I can deal with it.
I thought one of the most fascinating chapters in porn was when Tara Patrick
married that dude from the bay.
What band was that?
It was in bio hazard or something like that,
and then the dude started doing porn with her.
I was like,
wow,
that's kind of a shit in that mood.
Are you in this book?
Oh,
what are you at all?
She just talks about me.
Did you have,
well,
it's not,
let's not go to all TMC.
No,
read the book.
It's a great book actually.
I said,
yeah,
I read it.
It's really good.
It's interesting.
You really read a book.
Really Fuck Outta here.
That's the book you read.
Walk Outta here.
That's why I can't remember every last penny in get the fuck
it was right before that.
Your White,
who you're talking about,
huge cock went right into.
Do you think that you could ever do that?
You couldn't do that.
What do you think you could do that what that dude did?
I'm just started doing porn with her.
No,
she is so ridiculously hot though.
Oh,
she is really?
She knew what she was [inaudible] video of mine and we met and you know
I would see her after midnight.
A bunch.
Wow.
And that was about it.
I bet.
That's awesome.
She looks hotter now that she's had a baby.
I think like her body is insane now because she's got like just more curves or
something.
She's just amazing.
She's hot.
She's hot as fuck.
Yeah.
Thumbs up,
son of a bitch.
You son of a B a long time ago.
Hey,
whatever.
She's a nice person.
I met her,
she's a very cool,
uh,
but anyway,
this dude just looked down and started doing porn where they're like,
that's kind of a nutty move,
man.
You know?
Hey,
watch my fuck my wife.
There's something creepy about that.
Right?
Yeah.
Well the story in the book is,
I was kind of fucking around with that broad.
Uh Huh.
You know,
I guess she took it more serious than I did.
My wife read the book.
Oh No.
She was like,
everything you said is what she said.
Right.
Well that's good.
Basically.
I mean it was like,
you know,
booty call bakey situation,
but I guess on her end it was not,
you know,
I was more than that or something.
So special dude,
man,
I'm,
you know,
whatever.
But,
uh,
like I get a call on a Sunday morning and it's Dude Evan who I'd known for years
before that and like woke me up to like declare his love for her and I was like
wow,
whatever,
whatever.
I hung up the phone and I him back because he woke
me up.
I was like,
it's Sunday morning,
eight o'clock.
Cause like you just call me and like to clear love for like this for your point
girlfriend right now.
I was like,
that's,
it's Corny as hell.
Dot.
It's in the book.
My wife,
my wife read it.
She told me everything I said is in there.
It's cool.
It is housing.
That's pretty fun.
Corny dude.
Funny.
That is pretty corny man.
That was the end of that.
You would want to do that if like dude was your friend,
you know and yeah,
it was Sunday morning.
I was more mad about you fucking woke me up on a Sunday morning.
Come on.
Yeah,
when you fuck on camera.
Isn't it funny,
like automatically you become like,
if that's your choice,
automatically you become like you never,
it's like a caste system in society that's like,
that's a fuck up.
You never really get over.
He always used to be a porn queen,
you know?
Oh my a new one.
My wife was a nude model but she not too big.
Neverbounce yeah,
she never did no triple X.
Yeah.
It's once people watch it,
fuck,
you can see your body.
That's all well and no problems,
man.
I got no problem with it.
It's people watching people fuck is strange and I,
I've always tried to figure out why.
It's real weird.
My thing would be mostly how you going to,
I couldn't wife,
nobody that like my,
if I had a son with and 16 years later when God knows,
you know how available all that shit is going to be.
It's so easy now to find porn.
Oh Hey,
your kid shows up to you at 12 or whatever.
Like why are all my friends pointing at me or showing me pictures of my mom so I
can dig.
I mean that'd be just too,
I couldn't handle that.
Yeah.
That would be hard to deal with for sure.
But my,
my real question is,
it's really why are we so weird about our bodies and sex once the thing that
most people are looking forward to the most,
at least most dudes are looking forward to more than anything.
Most of the motivation that of of most men,
it's tried to get the most amount of pussy possible or the best blood.
See or the best wife,
the best girlfriend.
They want to be a bad motherfucker in order to do well with that.
That's a,
that's a weird desire when you really stop and think about it,
how much it,
it consumes and then you get to be around 40 and you start thinking about other
shit,
you know?
Yeah.
But what's crazy is they,
it's like unless you got married at like 20 or something,
those are the people that I'm really freak out when that's why everything's
falling apart in the middle.
Then your life,
you have too many questions that are run answered.
Yeah.
They didn't.
So their oats enough.
I mean,
you know,
there's what I call,
I answered,
I'd say 99.9% any questions I had on those levels,
I answered.
Oh,
but my question is why is it so weird to watch people fuck if everybody wants to
fuck?
Why is it so weird?
It's so like,
oh,
it's way weirder here than it is anywhere else in the world.
It's totally,
that's all our hangups that we'd been hammered in that the whole like a golden
age of the fifties and the modern family and all that been hammered into our
brains and and like,
you know,
sex is dirty and rotten,
not rotten,
dirty and nasty and should be conducted behind closed doors and not talked about
at all.
And only for fornication.
Yeah.
No,
only to exactly children's that old school man,
you know,
we still come from the generation now.
I believe that really believed that.
Yeah,
they,
well,
when they first landed here,
I guess that's what fucked the whole thing up is how many religious freaks made
the journey because they were being religiously persecuted in England,
which England is not nearly as religion as religious.
On the whole as America is.
So when the puritans came here,
I guess a lot of that shit stuck.
Puritans was the name because they were hardcore on let up.
I try not soak.
So Carl living a puritanical lifestyle.
Does that make sense?
So that's why in 2012 were still hung up.
Is it really because of that,
that it was formed by those people?
No,
but then all this,
you know,
I'm sure there's been many people that have reinforced the psychology for their
own benefits and you know,
yeah.
I wonder with all these cell phones now,
by the time kids get to be like babies of today and get to be grown women and
grown men,
we're going to have like where there's kind of everybody,
you're probably going to be able to access people's memories.
You're probably going to be able to walk,
watch porn in some sort of a fucking three dimensional virtual reality wear
goggles you put on and you,
you,
you live the scene.
People are going to make their own and you're going to,
we're going to be able to find people fucking,
we're going to have real problems.
This is going to be no privacy.
Yeah,
it's getting there and when that comes,
I mean I,
I,
you know,
I got my little Mac laptop.
I keep a sticker over the camera dog.
Whether I'm using it.
Do you?
Yeah,
I ain't fucking around man.
I believe that Yo,
somebody could turn that motherfucker and just start watching you.
You be off,
especially the cell phones and the microphone on your phone.
I bet.
I'm sure there's somebody could just sit there and like turn on camera.
Turn on microphone.
What's going on right now?
That's great.
You haven't done it yet.
I probably going to do it.
Yeah,
probably.
We just got a lot of me beaten off.
It's like you got good luck with that creep.
You want to release that.
You creeper
were so strange because we were close.
You know,
I think we would have a totally different attitude if we were naked all the
time.
Let's try it out.
Come on guys.
What?
It's just a weird thing of we've,
we've evolved.
We,
when,
what kind of a fucking animal evolves to the point where you could barely exist
in the world without being covered by something barely.
If you just walk around naked everywhere,
dude,
you're gonna get fucked up,
right?
You're not going to make it through that.
You're going to get sunburned.
Your skin is weak as shit.
You're going to get bit by things.
You'd get all infected and fucked up.
It tears easy.
My bleed to death.
We have to work with that
survival show recently where they had like the two guys that were survivalists,
but they were kind of opposite spectrum.
Dude's like one was a total fucking hippie dude.
One was like a Marine Guy.
Yeah.
Duels never wore shoes.
You only wore shorts and a tank top and that's how he,
you know,
he did his thing.
It was like,
you know,
I mean I think you could adapt readapt back to being able to live like that,
but it wouldn't be no instantaneous and it would suck.
It would suck.
It would suck hard.
There's no fun and looking for bugs.
Eat while you're walking barefoot and then Sean and your feet will start hurting
quick man,
because shoes are nice.
It is nice that they would know how to survive if the shit hit the fan.
But if the shit hit the fan,
what are the odds that you live in?
What are the odds of you live in?
If the shit really hits the fan,
I mean you talking about extinction events,
you talking about the,
the,
the real potential events,
things that have happened unquestionably documented all throughout history where
they're found supervolcanoes and all sorts of fucking meteor impacts.
And then there's all these records of them there.
They're discovering just now,
like 12,000 years ago,
they know there was a huge meteor shower that hit the world because there's
impact glass exists on the same,
uh,
the same strata,
like when they dig and make core samples exists in the same area all throughout
the world.
About 12,000 years ago,
something they got fucked up 12,000 years ago,
right.
Giant fucking asteroids coming through the sky.
Millions of people dead probably.
I think when,
if that kind of shit happens,
you're lucky if you get whacked.
That's what I think you want to be running around eating people's dogs and you
want to be running around trying to purify peoples.
So Souad trip on the fact that it wouldn't even take something that crazy.
Just let,
I keep telling people,
let the lights go out like that.
The power just shut down.
Yeah,
absolutely.
We're last time I was here,
I think it happened.
I was like,
that might be it,
man.
I might have to make a run for the guns right now.
I have a whole joke about how little we knew about the power,
but how much we need it.
I mean it's so important.
We don't,
no one even thinks about the fact there's essentially I would force of nature
that pulses through your fucking house all day.
Oh yeah.
I was in New York City when that big east coast blackout happened.
Man,
that was like crazy like tension because you know the whole city thought it was
something,
you know,
the next wave of whatever was coming at him.
Jesus cause you don't get no news,
you don't get me.
And then I walked around New York.
I remember just because we knew,
I remember what happened,
I plugged something in my hotel room,
something plugged in and wall,
few seconds later the power went out.
I was like,
oh,
did I overload my room or something?
And then I go out in the hall and it's out.
Go downstairs.
I realize the whole freaking cities that we went to times square just to look at
everything.
That was how it was crazy man.
Wow.
And then crazy.
And then work let out.
And like the streets were just flooded with people.
But the crazy,
the funniest thing to me was like instantly,
like dudes were like outside of their little bodega selling bottles of water for
like three times what they cost.
Like,
oh wow.
Hey,
$7 for a bottle.
The AVR and here,
you know like this man type.
Oh yeah man,
it was crazy.
You know?
And then there's the other half of you.
Then you walk up the street and you see like the dude who's just directing
traffic because nobody else is right.
It was crazy man.
It was a wild day.
Yeah.
Some dude's look forward to shit like that so they can stay in the street and
just tell cars where to go.
That's cool that people didn't go crazy though because that would be my fear
that everyone would just be like,
ah Nah.
I was a pretty,
you know of an la move,
you know.
It was a pretty,
I mean there was tension like what?
What happened?
What's going on?
Everybody was asking what happened,
what's going on?
Every once in a while somebody's cell phone would work,
but he like,
I remember thinking like that was the day I was like,
you know also has happened is the lights go out.
Yeah,
I was at,
they were sounding and then you'd walk down the street to the Deli that starts
selling the food for like almost half off because it's spoiling stuff is in the
fridge.
Like anything in the fridge.
Come on and take it please.
You know?
Wow.
But yet charging seven bucks for water.
You know what I mean?
The whole idea of cities is a people's mentalities would break down quick,
Joe.
Oh yeah.
It would get tribal.
It'll get lord of the flies real quick,
real quick.
The only way cities work as if there's power on,
cause if,
if not,
then it becomes a detriment then becomes way too many people and no resources.
You know,
when you're in the country at least you can go fishing.
you're in a city where are you gonna get your food and what the fuck?
Where's the food man?
They ain't no food coming in and it's instant.
It goes away because really it needs to be like pushed in constantly.
We've got this weird crazy ant hill sort of a situation going on and we need a
man to fill that motherfucker up with something we can digest to keep moving
cities or strange.
It's so if you were an alien,
and then what about when it,
nobody's picking up the trash every day.
Yeah,
it's true.
So you got both angles going on at the same time.
Pretty soon.
It's nuts.
Insane.
I was there and I'm in Harlem.
When they had a,
uh,
there was some sort of a,
a strike with the garbage men,
so they didn't pick up for a long time dude.
And there was,
and I'm not bullshitting,
seven,
eight,
nine foot high stacks and garbage bags on the street.
So you would have a narrow area to walk and to the left would be nine foot high
garbage for like a fucking half a block.
It was saying that we're everywhere.
Big Fat,
juicy rats running everywhere and you're like,
whoa,
people are living around this.
Like this is insane.
Right underneath.
That's all going on.
Pulsing underneath.
It's that whole time.
Has that ever happened on the upper east side or the upper west side of the ever
had like a garbage strike?
I've never been heard of seventies or something.
There was a citywide one that was pretty famous.
Is that one is I think so.
I don't know when you know this was,
I dunno what was causing them to not pick up the garbage.
I don't know what it was,
but it was somewhere in the 1990s,
the early nineties.
Like maybe 90 or 91.
I vaguely remember something about it,
but it was crazy.
I couldn't,
I couldn't believe it.
I was like,
what the fuck you mean you would want to get out of here as quick as possible if
some shit went down.
Like this is the worst place to be.
It's crazy man.
Why the fuck did it get like that where everybody's stacked on top of each
other?
It's just keep going straight down.
You know,
if you listened to the,
the,
you know,
the internets and uh,
the whole Illuminati is and all that.
I mean
there were all in the perfect area for him to just wipe us all out cause we all
live in,
it's like nobody lives in the country anymore.
Have a rich people go to the country day.
I've never understood how the rich people go to the country Hampton's day.
I've never understood the whole,
uh,
rich people want to white people out thing.
I've always felt like if you were a rich person,
you would need people to buy your stuff.
Whatever you're selling,
whatever you need,
people for recess.
You,
what are you doing?
You're going to kill people that seems sit like,
where are you going to make your money?
That doesn't seem to make any sense.
Yeah.
That seemed like a good Illumina.
I also saw a stat recently that was like,
you know,
how would they say the world's overcrowded and whatnot are overpopulated and I
could be Trevon,
but I'm pretty sure I saw a stat somewhere to said all the people in the world
would fit in the state of Texas.
Yeah.
Really?
Like with like some like elbow,
elbow room.
Like,
you know,
we'd all be able to stand in the state of Texas,
like all the people on the planet right now.
I don't know how crazy that is,
but I know I saw it somewhere.
Well,
if you look at us and compare it to any other animal where,
uh,
we've populated really every single part of the world,
we figured out a way to not just get there now,
but just get America though.
It's like really like last coast Cosa gang of he will east coast,
a whole gang of people and in the middle,
you know,
come on.
We do.
We toured for $11.
We know,
I mean there's,
I'm not saying there's not people,
but um,
but it's much more relaxed and it's a whole different kind of life.
It's like I've always found it like going five years backwards.
Right,
right,
right.
Like when you step out of the east or west coast,
just,
you know,
not in a disrespectful way.
I'm just saying it's like they're,
they're not as anxious and quick to be on the site.
No,
we like,
we like what's going on.
We'll slowly make moves on the things we like,
kind of thing.
What?
Denver is one of my favorite cities because Denver is like part city and park
country.
It's part like mountain people.
It's like a big community of mountain people.
So all the amount of people that got halfway and said,
you know what,
this,
this is,
this is good enough.
We're good.
We got some [inaudible] this is good.
Right?
He just killed an elk.
I worked good.
Let's wait here.
Why don't you guys walk around.
Do you see how many elk are out here in front of Ocean?
This is a good man.
I don't even see an ocean.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm a big fan of the ocean.
I love looking at it,
but it can't fuck with the mountains,
the mountains or some crazy shit you're taking.
You're taking mountains before ocean all day sun.
I'm all day.
If you ever been to Evergreen Colorado mountains with a lake
own Twitter lake time,
like in the last few years,
I played a couple of festivals in Switzerland.
One called the Montreux Jazz Festival is pretty famous and then this other one
called the blue balls festivals.
Hilarious.
But it's in a place called Lucerne and,
and they're both on lakes would just would mount as the crazy.
I could live there easily.
Every time I'm there I'm like,
Yo,
I need some,
I need to be balling out of control with a private jet and some of them Swiss
francs,
man,
I need to be over in Switzerland doing it.
The problem is,
man,
to make that kind of money.
Unless you're an entertainer,
you're someone's Kevin over.
Unless
you're an entertainer where you're selling something remarkable.
Cool.
Everybody hiding their money too.
Yeah.
That's why it's they keep it pretty.
Hi Denton that came in.
I don't want to come in there and fuck around.
Joe,
your old place.
Remember when I used to say that it looked like a trapper keeper.
You remember those,
uh,
those things you would have in school that you put your notebooks in uni?
They would have like boys,
like a beautiful picture of like a mountain in a scenic w you know,
Lake and stuff like that.
That's what like,
yeah,
it was ridiculous.
It's unbelievably beautiful.
You'd look out the back window and you'd go,
I can't believe they let me stay here.
Like,
this is crazy.
I can't believe people allowed to be here.
It was just too silly.
You're in the mountains,
like literally in the mountains,
but you're,
you're around there with everything you see in porcupines every day and deer all
day,
all day.
She was getting air back here up in the hill.
Really?
Oh,
you can get all of the all day.
Yeah.
Pasadena has bears,
man.
They had bears jumping into people's swimming pools recently.
I always like to live somewhere that's cause we were talking about craziness
man.
I liked to live places that have resources like other than like,
okay well if things went really bad I can walk right out my back yard marked
down that mountain and go find me a dear.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know.
Well I've always said Ted Nugent is live in the best,
you know what he does?
He is a high fence place where he has like thousands of acres and they're all
fenced in and these kids essentially got wild game running around his whole
fucking giant ranch and he just sets up stands.
He's got like feeders so they know where the animals are going to come late and
it's essentially shooting fish in a bucket.
And he asked to shoot a certain amount of them just to manage it because it's
got a certain amount of land.
Like you have to monitor how many,
how many sheep you have,
how many deer you have.
But that is way healthier and way smarter than going to a fucking supermarket.
I mean,
you know,
it's to see the animal before he shoots it.
He does all the butchering himself.
He makes the cuts of meat.
He grows his vegetables like this dude doesn't need shit.
Like that's really the way to go.
I mean,
he's got guns,
he's got guns and he doesn't need shit.
He can eat from his yard,
run out.
He got bows and arrows.
He uses the bows in the house more than he uses the guns.
He's always bow hunting,
man.
The nude.
Yeah,
he's a crazy fuck when it comes to war.
But I'll tell you why.
When it comes to like living your life sustainably,
that motherfucker's got it nailed when it comes to his,
he's right about hunting like you.
People are crazy to think that hunting is bad because you either want one of two
things you want,
either want hunting or you want to be hunted because that's the only way you
keep the deer population down.
You have one of two options.
Either you're going to hunt the deer or you're going to put mountain lions out
there that eat deer and anything you need steer can eat you motherfucker.
Oh yeah.
And he you a lot easier than once in a while.
You hear about it back here like,
oh,
there was like people that don't want on to medium size dog getting snatched out
of my backyard by a mountain lion.
Yeah,
I got those Pasadena bearers.
Yeah.
Oh,
the folks at home,
these are not.
These are the gay bear.
Oh,
that's a for gay dudes
were Harry.
You fuck each other?
Burt crushers everywhere.
There's that is the Google search.
It's really borrowed.
A few did.
Roids right.
I got a hairy Bert.
Well,
you're pretty fucking Harry to minister.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You'd make a good bear if you got on the sauce.
I started doing some heavy squats.
Yeah,
he'd be a,
you would be a good bear.
Wow.
I wouldn't be so bear and her cubs were drinking out of some
ladies pool on that.
On the news.
Crazy.
Huh?
Which this is,
you know,
Pasadena is only an hour,
not even an hour,
an hour from arrowhead.
Arrowhead is,
you know,
it's right down.
It was like 40 minutes away,
45 minutes away,
which is legit wilderness.
I mean that is yours.
Pasadena Altadena,
which is obviously the hills above Pasadena.
And then beyond that it's just wild mountains.
Wild mountains.
Yeah.
And then there's,
you know,
two miles from,
from here.
You're in the woods.
Yeah,
yeah,
it's true.
Yeah.
This is a different sort of area.
Pasadena is and the rest of La,
they say that what Pasadena was was in the 20s and you know,
they're making movies and shit like a resort town out there.
There was a railroad that went up to out the Gina and like all these rich folks
had their little that kind of like sorta like Hampton,
like kind of thing going on up there.
What is the atmosphere like now?
Cause Pasadena,
I know like Pasadena has more crime now that I think it's ever had before.
I have to dean like the Beverly Hills of Pasadena.
All.
The crazy thing is there's always a lot of movies getting shot because none of
the houses are the same.
They're like Spanish style next to a colonial style next so they can like make
it look like anywhere in America.
So it's all like older like houses from like people that made him like who who,
how did they get melt out here?
Because what they were telling me was the Pasadena was where the studio
producers and people would live with the actors.
We live in the Hollywood hills.
Right.
That's something out to Dina is what I'm talking about.
And like in the twenties I believe it was like Kinda that 20s and 30s it was
like a little resort area where you could see some of those houses that are for
sale online and Alta Dena and they've got some like really old houses.
Turn of the century houses.
Yeah.
It's crazy shit man.
That's a good area man.
Yeah,
I love that.
They,
I like animals and deer and what's it Altadena where the lady had the mountain
lions sitting in their front driveway and she was taking pictures of it.
It might've been out,
I think it was,
yeah,
it was a really recently.
If it wasn't Altadena it was real close to that with some ladies are fucking
driveway and there's a mountain lion just lying there just chilling.
Yeah.
I think I saw that just enjoying himself.
Just Chelan I've been gone most of the summer though.
Do you ever think about living anywhere else?
Like any other part of the country?
I like Nashville.
Nashville's great.
I like Nashville is like,
and you leave,
you dropped 10 minutes anywhere outside of like downtown and you're in the
country.
Yeah,
you're in the country.
You can go out your back door and shoot no shoot stuff.
Yeah you can shoot your guns and you know like I went and sat with this one cat
and was playing guitar with him one night again because he had a little dog,
you know,
that little something for me to,
partake of.
So we playing guitar together and he was like,
we can go outside,
shoot some guns.
Cause like,
yeah,
the guy that he was renting a place and told me it was for sale and I was like,
you know how it was like 25 acres and like you know,
house and all this three two barns and how much,
he was like,
oh like six.
And I was like in my brain was like 6 million.
Like yeah,
wow,
6 million.
I was like,
man,
that's a pretty good price.
He was like,
Nah man,
I'm like six 600,000 I was like,
are you shitting me?
I was like,
Yo man,
I might have to,
I might have to do that one day.
Just get out of extras.
Grabbed me,
grabbed me,
grab a ranch.
Yeah man.
You know what else is great?
Asheville,
North Carolina.
You have been up there?
I have,
I don't know if I've been particularly there.
I've been to North Carolina many times.
I've only looked at it online,
but apparently it's like this like really cool spot in the mountains where it's
small population,
lot of stoners,
Lotta Lotta like musicians and like really cool people and they're living in
like one of the most picture as parts of the world.
Like those,
like the mountains,
like the Asheville,
North Carolina,
that whole area on man.
Dude,
it's ridiculous.
Just lakes,
trees and shit.
Same kind of property.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
man.
It's sure.
Asheville itself,
it's probably a little more expensive,
but outside of it,
man,
she can get giant chunks of land.
Man,
you can get just beautiful setups,
houses on lakes and shit.
Can you shoot your guns?
I'll sure if you have a certain amount of acreage.
There's a show mountain men that I watch,
one of the dudes is in North Carolina,
but I've seen those commercials for it.
It's this shit.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're interested in this subject,
my favorite show on TV is the one where they hunt the gators,
swamp
swamp people,
and a perfect example of why hunting should exist.
If those guys didn't hunt the gators,
they hunted every year and gators would be eating a lot of children.
Yeah,
well it'd be a lot more gators.
I look at it.
Well that's insane.
Yeah,
that's Asheville.
I mean,
are you kidding me?
That water?
It's paradise up there.
It's fucking paradise.
Yeah.
I mean I would have to see what it would be like man.
We need,
I would think about living in a place like
or laying on them private jets and hanging out with them.
Hedge Fund type motherfuckers.
Man.
You don't get any time with any hedge fund motherfuckers that needs,
you know,
their bat mitzvah or Bar Mitzvah played.
You know what I mean?
I'm just trying to get down and be your home and you know I won't come at you
too tough.
I'll throw some of that advice at me.
You know what?
He helped me get into the fast lane,
get into the,
I'm stacking my chips,
but it's slow grind.
I'm looking for that hedge fund dude.
Like I like,
I like every last,
I want to smoke some dope.
Where are you at?
Holler.
That's what I'm talking about.
You don't want that money,
Bro.
You want
the money that you're making.
You don't want that hedge fund money that that money smells like blood.
But you know what,
by a lot of soap
detergent,
you know what's really going to bum me out,
man.
It sounds crazy.
But when,
when they start making real engines for cars,
you know a friend of mine had a Prius and I know it's the future.
I know it's progress.
The thing makes no noise.
It's electric.
It's awesome on gas uses less resources but goddamn it was boring as he drove
away.
I was like listen to what the fuck that sounds like.
Are we gonna not enjoy driving anymore?
Is it really going to get to that at some point?
I think there's still always going to probably do it just for the,
you know,
there's going to be one company like Porsche is going to be like,
I ahead.
We're always going to make a engine,
you know,
wonder if there'll be allowed to because they're putting all sorts of crazy
restrictions on them as far as like,
you know,
the future.
Like what they're going to have to be able to do as far as the emissions.
So why a lot of companies are forced to go to turbo charging because uh,
the,
the emission standards are so high,
they're going to lose the thrill of what an engine is like.
I want to,
whenever you come over here,
I've got,
and Van,
I love that fucking car.
You drive that Audi.
Come on,
do it.
We could try it for a week or so.
Dove car.
It's,
he's got to get an a real clutch though.
A real manual transmission bro.
That little,
those little paddle shifters,
the paddle shifters,
it's no fun now the car,
like that song in Los Angeles,
it last name,
I can't fucking happen if it's going to be the only car you drive apps,
you know?
Yeah.
And it's,
I'm just,
I'm just a car was an impulse buy man.
It was,
I went into the spot mad at BMW cause like they had jacked up their price on the
seven series and I was mad.
I was like,
it went from like 80 to 110 or something.
And I was just like,
man,
that,
I was like,
okay.
And I was like,
I'm going to go just,
I'm just,
I was just going to go look at some other things.
I looked at her,
a bunch of other cars,
looked at an Audi and I looked at a Bentley and I looked at all these other cars
and I was thinking maybe it was just weak sauce to me,
boring.
And then,
I mean,
this was a row of dealers of all these cars.
It's right here.
Actually,
I won't mention them cause they ain't paying me,
but you know,
it's always fine.
But to get back out to where my car was,
I had to walk back into the Audi dealership and that's when I saw they had an
all white or eight in the corner.
And I just went over looking at it like,
wow,
that's kind of sharp,
you know?
And Kate came over and started talking to me and he was like,
yeah,
I got a black on black one out back.
I was like,
I know I'm not going to buy his car.
Right.
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
Show it to me man.
You know,
show it to me and like how you want to take it for a spin.
And he's,
I was like,
oh I could drive it.
He's like,
Nah,
I could take you for a spin though,
you know.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
okay.
I was like,
well whatever,
let's go.
I've got time to kill.
Took me first span.
Took me up until we're in backwards.
The rose bowl is and then pulled the car over and got out and he's trying to
kiss you.
I didn't know.
I was worried though for a second cause he pulled the car over man.
He pulled the car over.
I was like,
what are you doing man?
And then he got out the car and he's like,
yo go ahead and you could drive the car.
And I took it.
That was the smartest thing he ever day cause I took that car like 15 minutes.
Just went nuts.
Did you ever had a car like that before?
No.
Not that.
Not like sport car like that.
I wasn't eating.
I mean I had way back when like at eight 51st came off for the BMW.
I had that and then I drove,
I can't fuck with what you got done.
And then I drove,
I drove seven series for the all the rest of that time I was really like a,
that's what I did.
I'd always have a truck and I'd have my beat,
my little BMW seven so your car is mid engine car and that layout is the best
layout as far as like handling feel.
And that's such a great balance on rails man.
Yeah,
the engine is actually in front of the rear wheels so it just rides like a
fucking dream.
Just rides on a dream.
It's fun.
It's a meaningful cost space.
Shit,
I got the aid,
I didn't get the 10 because that's the car they had right there.
Right.
And I said,
give it to me.
I want this car right now.
Realistically you don't need that 10 and if you want it,
what we're saying eight cylinder over 10 solar.
But if you want it to,
there's a company that puts a supercharger under the eight and makes it more
powerful than the V 10 and it doesn't cost that much and it's safe and they know
what the fuck they're doing.
They're not doing it by a long way,
like you're saying it the way it grounds it sounds awesome man.
It was nice.
The supercharger,
we'll add a little extra wide and keeps the little boy and me alive.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's fun.
Right?
It's telling me I have a,
I'm one of those uh,
Shelby gt 500 mustangs.
You know what?
Those are all ways.
It was a,
it's a one of the,
one of the newer ones and the sound of it alone.
I swear to God,
it just gives me a smile.
It makes me smile when I hit the gas and I shifted gears just to hear that
engine roar it for I think from men.
I don't think any one has ever like fully documented it,
but I think there's like a physiological thing that happens when you hit like a
strong engine.
I think there's something happening to your body.
It makes you actually feel good.
You know,
it was like an animal grounded.
I think it's,
it probably produces testosterone or something like that.
I've read that.
I feel like I've read that.
You're laughing,
right?
No,
no.
I,
I could see it probably doing something like that.
He was giving him,
the first night I had a dog,
I was just taking it out and I was hitting corners doing 35 45 for Cornell
drive.
Dude.
I was like,
there's a,
there's a button you hit on it where the shocks fill up with fluid so you don't
even lean magnetic suspension.
It just,
yeah,
it was like wow.
It was like being on a freaking roller coaster man.
Is this?
Yes.
It's called the Audi r eight and they have a v eight version of ie 10 version
and actually a lot of people think that the [inaudible] doesn't handle as well
because it's still got a bigger engine and there's a little bit more weight
biased.
Yeah.
The engine and the v eight is smaller engine and a lot of people actually enjoy
that car more,
but they started to put a supercharges on them,
so they jack it up to like 560 horsepower and they're insane.
Insane.
I chew up tires like crazy and great.
I love cars,
man.
I just loved that someone invented it.
Such a fucking,
you know,
you're getting a good car and took it to that level.
So that's like a space man.
Well,
that's odd.
I was like,
man,
that's a bad ass car.
There's cars now like the,
you know,
like the Shelby Shelby gt 500 they have a new one that's out that 660
horsepower.
It's a fucking ridiculous thing to own.
Nobody should be able to just go into a store and without proving that you don't
have to drive a God damn race car,
get a car stock off the shelf with a 660 plus horsepower engine,
but you can go get it.
You can go get it right now and you hit that ball and it just,
it just exciting.
It was good.
Little little,
little goosebumps.
Even if you don't drive it fast,
like you got a smile on your face while you're driving.
Women will never understand that.
They just want to look good,
just want to look good hair in their car and have a nice shiny clean car.
Something,
something to stand it down just on a different level.
But the ones who want to be in that car and then when they know they'd rather be
in that car,
then the guy with the rust it up to her cell.
That's true.
But what I'm saying is I think,
uh,
there's like especially muscle cars to something incredibly masculine about
them.
Something,
something that I don't think I'm so a woman will have a complete tune into.
It's an,
it's a beast.
You,
they sound like bs.
Controlling a beast.
Your hardest thing.
500 horses worth of power.
This is a ridiculous 500 horse all about.
That's why I say it keeps the little boy in me alive.
He's playing with.
I got fucking 400 horsepowers 400 horsepower and the aluminum car with all wheel
drive,
but but rear wheel drive characteristics because I'd only ever gives 30% of the
power of the real world,
so it just helps you in corners and shit like that thing in sport and I'll put
that shock thing on.
It's crazy.
It's fun.
I mean,
I'm going to lie.
Well,
when you think about technology and you think about how much things have
progressed,
one of the best ways to look at it,
it's cars,
cars,
cars.
Today you get like they have cars that goes zero to 60 in less than three
seconds and that's normal and you can get them at Nissan.
Okay,
that's insane.
A Nissan GTR is zero to 60 in 2.7 or 2.8 seconds.
That's mind blowing.
It's so hard to wrap your head around the fact that one,
two,
three you're going 60 fucking miles an hour.
That's an insane car for a regular person to be able to buy and they're making
them better every year.
Every year it's faster.
Every year they got this with Germany,
they have this course called the Nurburgring.
It's like the one that they benchmark a lot of performance cars on it because
there's all these turns and twists.
So it gives a real accurate representation of how fast you could drive with this
car in the real world.
And those motherfuckers go around it and it was insane.
Speed is videos of them online.
I'll watch them for hours on end.
I'll watch like here's a Ferrari four five eight on the Nurburg rang,
here's,
and they showed them to you from the cockpit.
So it's like all of them around seven minutes and 50 seconds,
seven 40 seconds.
So for seven minutes,
just sitting in there with the youtube on screen and going,
how could,
how could you not appreciate that?
How can you not appreciate what somebody is engineered?
Something that hurls you around corners,
like slightly sideways controlling it.
So
wild a watch,
man.
I spent most of my summer in Europe,
so every time we were on the Autobahn I was,
man,
I wish I had my car here.
Just just stop it.
Just to open it up.
I've opened it up over there to 10 that back over the mountains where there
ain't much later than they got it up to like one 60 sound,
the two tens of beautiful.
Then I started getting real jittery,
like the highly copters going to see me here,
so I'm going to turn into like a high speed pursuit on the news and so I got
back down.
Well those days are
on the way out,
man.
With the advent of drones,
you're not going to be able to get away with that shit.
They'll have drones in the night.
Sky Monitoring people speed.
Here we go on.
You got you.
Got You on video doing 106
ah man.
Yeah.
You won't be able to fuck with it.
I mean this,
there's no way.
There's no way they're gonna not gonna have that locked down.
If there really are going to be 30,000 drones in the sky in 10 years.
That's what they're said.
Surveillance drones.
He the fuck crafts.
They're going to cut back on all the fun.
Yeah.
Well that's when you,
when you bought the city man.
Oh,
they're going to have it out there too,
dude.
They're going to have it everywhere.
It's more,
it's easier probably to notice probably,
unless you're talking about these little mosquito Mike robot things that you see
every once in a while pop up.
Yeah.
Well that's another thing that I heard that was really creepy about some cars,
some cars they without even you even knowing it,
they keep a data log of how fast you've driven it.
It's like a,
they can go into it and they can like access it and they can find out like,
what are you doing asshole?
You're going 150 fucking miles an hour where you want to track like,
what are you,
what are you doing here?
Like what,
why are you going this fast?
Like they can find that out from,
you could find out where you were from,
your gps locations.
It's like you're,
you're carrying a record of all your whereabouts.
I'll be a little blank box somewhere in there.
My show there is,
especially if you're,
I don't put anything past anyone.
Uh,
have you heard of this?
Um,
this a new thing that was released by wikileaks called trap wire.
Uh,
I'm having a dude come on.
The guy who broke the story,
he's coming on the 28th,
um,
I think it's the 20th.
Anyway,
the,
um,
w what it is,
is they've figured out a way to take all surveillance cameras from all over the
country and work them through a centralized database where they were literally
store all of the information,
like every movement that's happening in cities and in areas,
they've got a complete massive database on everything that everyone's ever done
for like the last few years.
Like they're starting to do it in these,
in these areas.
And they're,
they're putting it in a centralized anyways without letting anybody know.
Wow.
It's crazy.
I don't know the,
but somehow or another they're all linked through,
you know,
homes,
homeland security or whatever the fuck it is.
It's whatever organization is taking the,
from all these different
places.
But there are amassing a database of all of our activities all the time without
anybody even knowing about it.
And what's really crazy about that is that this is just this,
this marks and ethic.
All right,
it's,
it marks like this is what they're thinking.
They would like to monitor us all the time.
So they're doing it as much as they can.
We'll eventually,
the technology is going to be better.
So as technology gets better,
they're going to have shit everywhere.
They're going to be able to,
they're going to be to look at you everywhere.
That's what they do.
It's what they do.
He can't stop them.
How's that going to stop?
Are we gonna stop that?
It's going to make for a lot
better a those videos like this hidden camera videos.
I could look at this person and he fell down and
cat videos cause your cats do a lot of wacky shit while you were at work and
this way you can go back and review.
Let's see what skippy got in to today.
Oh,
you little asshole dragon out of the toilet again.
I heard there was a study recently where they put these cameras on cats and
they,
they found out that cats are,
they murder way more than they originally thought.
Like these catches did nothing but like murder animals,
squirrels,
birds,
insects.
And they just are like,
they go and killing sprees every time they go out of the house.
No,
I've never been a cat tree.
I've always felt doing,
we're kind of the creepy dark.
Oh yeah,
I saw,
I see.
For me it was also one time I was many,
many years ago.
I'm gonna mess them with some broad,
she had a cat and I saw a cat go from the counter and jump up onto the top of
the like shower door,
which is like,
you know,
it's like jumping on a balance beam but 12 feet above that if you were a gymnast
jumping 12 feet up and landing on a balance beam perfectly well and that's when
I was like,
Yo,
I don't,
I don't trust anything that could do that.
It was half magical thinking,
fuck you up.
Like,
I'm not talking about running and jumping,
like standing there and springing up onto some shit and I was like,
no,
that was some,
that was some magical shit.
Rod Iron,
iron railing that curls on my staircase and this wrought iron iron railing is
only about three fingers wide.
Like maybe three of my fat fingers won.
My cat walks it.
He walks it like a tight rope all the way up to the top.
Yeah,
he's there 12 feet above,
you know,
a hard stone floor.
It's motherfucking okay.
He's just chilling.
I know.
Fear of man.
There's all kinds of old like,
like you know,
creepy tales about cats and they used to like sit on the chest of children and
suck their breath down and go.
They wouldn't let him.
I did lie on babies because they're warm and when they lie on the 18 months
smother them.
Yeah.
That's like that Shit's real.
You know,
they turned that into many of folk.
But could you imagine if you're fucking it up in your kitchen,
like smothered your kid?
Oh,
it's so scary,
man.
That's so cool.
Or too smart.
I mean cancer just too damn smart.
They creeping cats,
robots.
We just don't know it yet and totally like really don't give a shit about you
unless they want something from you.
They want to be pet all the time.
They want constant or fuck
you.
Yeah.
It's funny,
Eddie Bravo was just starting to realize cats,
cancer cunts.
Now that he has kid,
he loves his son so much.
Ma'Am.
I tell him,
you know,
he's talking to me about how much he loves his bunny,
how much he loves cats and I'm like,
yeah,
that's all nice and good.
Wait till you see little man.
Wait till you have a son that you were ready to kill those cats with a hammer.
Trust me.
Obviously I was joking around.
I have cats.
I love my cats.
They're creepy,
but I love him.
But man,
he now,
he's like this fucking cats.
They make noise when the kids asleep on purpose,
they're trying to wake him up.
Like he,
I try to keep them out of the room.
So they go in there and knock shit over,
let,
they'll knock shit over and run around the,
you know,
the hallway.
They're like,
they're fucking with him and he's realizing it and he's like,
oh my God,
I'm living with a bunch of cunts.
Cancer,
crazy jealous little twats.
I would get a cat,
like if I lived like in the hills or something and I had,
you know,
something I'd have,
I keep a cat like a outdoor indoor cat.
Those are bad for bad news for the sake of keeping off any,
you know,
rodents and whatnot.
You shouldn't fuck with outdoor indoor cats for the simple reason of parasites.
Outdoor,
an outdoor cat.
I'll give them all outdoor or all indoor.
But even I would have,
they served a purpose like as just strictly a pet for me.
I'm a dog guy,
always been a dog guy.
Well,
you know,
feral cats,
people have traditionally had them on farms in order to just,
I mean,
semi feral just to keep the,
the rat population down because whenever you have a farm,
you're going to have a lot of rodents.
But that cat parasite shit is no joke,
man.
A lot of people have real problems in their life because of this cap parasite.
And it's,
uh,
it's,
it's affected massive amount of Europe,
massive amount of South America not even hit.
It's all,
it's all toxo plasma.
It's,
um,
they're just discovering it within the last few years.
And,
uh,
one of the things that are discovering is that it leads to a disproportional
amount of motorcycle victims.
So I think it affects your judgment and a,
it also,
they said there's a lot of soccer teams,
like,
like really successful soccer teams,
uh,
come from countries where they test high with high levels of Toxoplasma because
it makes you reckless.
It makes men,
so apparently it makes them more aggressive and may perhaps even generate more
testosterone.
But essentially it's a fucking parasite that you get from cats.
And it,
it completely rewires the way you're,
you're thinking is like Dave,
there's one as an article that's written online.
It was a fascinating article by a neurosurgeon who has it and he knew something
was wrong.
It's totally incurable when you have it,
you can live with it,
but it affects your judgment and it comes from fucking cats and it's creepy.
It's a behavioral change her.
So cats get it from rats and rats.
What happens is the rat gets it and when the rat gets it,
the rat gets sexually attracted.
The smell of cat piss.
So it's some renders itself basically to runs right to the whole,
like every night shower learn it is and it's real.
I mean that's really scary.
That is like m night Shyamalan here and we all sit around when thinking about,
you know,
how arrogantly we're going to ruin or kill them,
take
over the world or anything.
I was,
it takes is one cat parasite dude and we're all screwed man.
You know what I mean?
The wrong one.
And,
and we're let that aerosol eyes.
Well,
they say that sneeze on a plane.
50 million people are affected by it in this country alone.
Crazy 50 million in Brazil.
It's like 60% and parts of France at one point in time it was as high as 80% now
it's down to the 50s but 50% that's half the fucking people have this cat
parasite.
Half of them that changes your behavior.
Wow.
Fucking nuts.
There's a guy named [inaudible] Paul Ski.
I got to get them on this podcast.
I have to talk to Tim.
Talk to them about this,
if you ever has free time.
But he's a professor and a,
he specializes in it and it's crazy.
And he'd tell you,
he's the one who,
uh,
he has a great video.
Sucks.
So Plasma Toxoplasma Gondii,
toxoplasmosis Gundy.
I think it was the actual name that out the fucking terrifying man.
That's why outdoor cats can go fuck themselves.
You know,
you gotta get up gotta keep away from those creepy bitches.
They might,
they might get you with their dirty shit.
General not like cats,
man.
And I'm a Leo,
but isn't that weird?
Be What?
A crazy.
It's cold.
We're all Leos here.
Yeah.
And we're all getting along.
Isn't it crazy though,
that you could,
you could figure out a way to wire an animal's Dick,
so it gets hard when it smells like cat piss the pice of its murderer.
Could you imagine some devious Stevie shit that's physically and spiritually
just
that's just,
that's an next,
that's Freddy Krueger nightmare shit right there that somebody could just spit
on you or transfer a fluid or breathe on you.
And all of a sudden now there are agents at work within your body to make you
behave differently.
So guys,
to the killing of you by that person would be made much easier.
Wow,
that's awesome.
And a whole species like cats,
you're going,
your cat's like,
what the fuck cats,
the one thing that wants to kill you all the time and nature is like,
Yep,
Yep.
That's where we want to go next.
Go over there,
please smell that.
I mean,
it's almost smells like cat.
It's almost impossible to imagine that that wasn't engineered.
It makes you stop and go,
who the fuck is working behind the curtain here?
That seems engineered.
That seems like if you wanted to point to some sort of intelligent design of the
universe,
I think things like that are compelling topics,
not necessarily evidence but compelling topics.
When it comes to the debate of there being some sort of intelligence to this
whole thing.
What the fuck?
I mean how does it randomly happened?
He like,
if we could go scratched a chicken and a week later it's at our doorstep cooked
like waiting for us to eat it.
Yeah.
We just throw some powder out there in the field and he just had the urge to
throw itself on a roasting grill and and feed itself to,
it's a hard dick wandering with their stupid black rat eyes.
Dead eyes looking for cat piss with a heart on fuck kind of world is this.
You know what this happened?
Look at the TV
videos of cats doing hilarious shit with their bodies.
You can watch those.
My daughter watches those four hours.
That's might be aliens student.
They might be,
I think their robot.
I think their technology,
well,
I just think they're super killers.
I think that nature needs cleanup and in order to make sure that the,
the limping fucks don't make it,
there's cats.
That's really what it is.
And they're,
they're,
they're the little ones.
That's what I'm saying.
Like the devil picked it up and walked away,
got up on two legs and walked out.
It's the most,
what's the name of that?
Just so people could see a cat walking on.
Oh,
thriller cat thriller cat doctor about week for it.
Thriller Chat.
Wait for it.
Oh,
it's so silly.
They're nature's cleanup man.
They're there to make sure that,
uh,
that it's tough to learn when they do,
when somebody domesticated cat who decided that have any shit and piss in a box
was a great idea.
It's only keeping the house if you're going to keep me in the house,
they have to have a place to shit.
Dear Armin has it go in the toilet and
she has this bald cats where they're all shaved and she's trained it to just use
the toilet.
I guess.
That's right.
If you're not letting it out of the house,
could you imagine the things that her cat is soon?
Oh God,
no wonder where the cat goes.
Traumatized.
Doesn't even know it's a cat.
Cat pieces is a person that can't talk,
doesn't know what the fuck is up.
Yeah.
It's weird having an animal shitting in your house.
It's gross.
Yeah.
Fucking nasty.
I'm not down with it anymore.
I will turn off to me like if I would show up at some chicks house or something
and I would smell that smell.
It's awful.
Oh there's a litter box in gross.
Especially if you're lazy and you know,
clean the piss out and you walk in the house.
Do you have that ammonia smell?
Like what?
That's so dangerous
for you?
Like they're,
they,
they're always watching animal hoarders on Netflix,
which is one of the worst fucking TV shows in the whole entire road.
I don't know if you've ever watched it.
There was even one guy that had like over like 10,000 rats.
Like is his wife died and then he bought a rat for some reason cause she liked
rats.
And then there's just thousands and thousands of rats.
But uh,
one thing is the ammonia.
There was this guy that owned I think 90 cats in a one bedroom or something like
that and the ammonia was so bad,
like the toxic level with something like crazy,
like 12% he had it like 90% like his air quality was just all ammonia.
Wow.
That's crazy.
It was just sometimes with the wifey man,
every once in a while somebody will have so much stuff they'll put like a flat
dead cat.
Oh yeah.
Wait,
watch animal hoarders,
they will freak you out.
They find dead cats.
All the weird
that a lot of people do that and you start storing animals in their house.
They need more animals or just even junk.
Yeah,
junk orders.
Was it crazy?
That's her best.
Like throw out old newspapers once.
Like my table gets too cluttered.
I stopped some of this shit.
Got to get thrown out.
Man,
that's out refreshed myself by got rid of all the magazines in my office.
I had like a stack of magazines stack.
Maybe you got to let go.
Some of my stuff.
It was like maybe 200 magazines.
I've been good at that though.
I don't even have a lot of my own memorabilia and things like that cause I give
everything away and I,
that's beautiful.
You know what I mean?
I wound up giving,
you know,
it'll impact them more than an impact.
You,
you know,
to have a guy,
he's a real Everlast memorabilia in your house.
You know,
it's just,
you know,
things sooner.
I've had it all lost at all,
had it all I said all a couple of times.
So it's like I'm really attached to like not being attached.
Well that is the thing.
That's the best story.
The had it all lost.
It all.
Got It.
Backstories to best store in here.
People love that.
They love people that fuck up.
I do.
I love people that,
cause I know that's what I do.
I have fun.
I love people that can figure things out or that get through adversity or that
go over a hump or that get thrown a curve ball and they figured out how to hit
it next time.
Hey,
you know,
they're the most interesting.
I get up the next day.
Yeah.
I'm still gonna.
You know,
I remember like in the middle of my troubles,
my troubles have them because of,
you know,
I had to,
uh,
I quit house of pain.
I was doing a record in my label.
Didn't even believe in the whole white board.
Right?
Yeah.
We went over that and then,
you know,
I'd given up,
like I had the tax,
my accountant ripped me off for some taxes and I canceled my insurance.
So it was like the perfect storm of like,
here's the perfect time for your heart thing to happen to you right now.
Well,
it's a perfect movie though,
you know,
and then the bounce back with a bounce back was kind of luck,
put your lights on that was not locked to that song.
It's tremendous,
man.
Yeah.
You know what,
that's,
you know,
that was a result of,
like I said,
Song with you and coming out to hospital so,
well,
you know,
I wrote the song and do play a little bit of that again on his album.
Put a little bit of that on,
but God damn,
that's a good song,
dude.
Oh,
and then that song,
that song had,
that song had some real feeling in it,
man.
There was a lot going on in that song.
Yeah.
But I remember like my accounts,
it was telling me to file for bankruptcy and all this and I was like,
you know what?
I ain't going to do it.
I ain't going to do it cause I ain't,
you know what I mean?
God forbid I ever really had to do it,
but I was like,
I'm,
I paint.
My Dad says,
the way I look at it,
I just like,
you know,
I got screwed over by this guy.
I'm not going to tell 10 people over here.
I owe money to screw you because,
right.
Because I got screwed.
I don't play that game.
You know what I mean?
Bankruptcy is kind of a tricky little situation.
Huh?
I just remember the day I got the call from my accountant and said,
you know,
my new accountants,
that was,
uh,
that I broke even like that everything was paid.
All my debts,
my medical bills,
everything was paid.
And you know,
now you could start putting some money back in the bank.
Took like a year.
Wow.
Some people it takes say whole life,
you know?
Yeah.
People can hit a spiral man.
Oh,
you love her.
Who is cooler than Carlos Santana?
Is anyone ever lived that's cooler than that guy?
He's undeniable.
I don't know that guy right there.
It's pretty fucking cool.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
but come on man.
Carlos Santana.
What was it like working with him man?
Um,
it was cool.
It was like,
um,
I had written that song.
I mean we've gone over the story a little bit.
Last time I'd written that song and I had it,
but like,
why are you forcing his blues was done and,
uh,
I was doing science night live.
I don't know if we talked about that part.
I was actually,
you know,
which was one of my like,
bucket list things,
you know,
playing Saturday night.
Right.
Growing up as a kid.
That's why I learned about a lot of music.
Um,
so I'm playing soccer in our lab.
We're doing,
we're doing like the day before rehearsal or something and somebody comes in the
rooms.
I killed Carlos,
the antennas and the building and he's looking for you.
And I was like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Kind of shut up.
And like,
literally like 30 seconds later,
Carlos Santana walks in the room.
Wow.
And uh,
the guy who produced that song,
me,
Dante Ross had taken the liberty,
heard they were looking for songs,
he took the liberty of sending them the song and Santana fell in love with the
song.
It was the way I understand in the way of stories told to me is,
uh,
it was the first song chosen for that whole project.
So,
you know,
it was,
it was cool.
It was an honor.
You know,
I was like,
I got this song and I was going to save it from my second record,
but it was like,
you know,
they just seemed like an opportunity to,
I should take,
fuck yeah,
man,
be right next to Carlos motherfucking Santana
any anywhere.
I mean like,
you know,
and he was adamantly,
I'm not going to say the word bank cousin implies like some kind of,
you know,
really want to be involved,
wanted that song for his record.
He was like,
Yo,
I want this song for my record and I,
and it was almost like I can't take no for an answer.
How do I,
you know,
he was basically let me know he was being real cool about it.
Let me know how much he wanted that song.
And then you're like,
you're buttered up by,
by Santana.
So it's like,
yeah.
All right.
Carlos Santana,
who is like made it through better than that guy.
He's made it through better than any of them.
If you think about all the people from his era and generation,
they're all dead and he's still relevant.
You know,
just stick around.
Fuck yeah.
Stick around and still blow it out man.
His music is still married to the Cindy.
Yeah.
Black men that I remember that drummer used to be in Lenny Kravitz's band.
Check with the big truck.
Yeah,
that's his wife.
And she's about,
I think she'd been drumming with him too.
I think faith plays for him.
Wow.
Yeah.
Very few people like hit that cool level like that Carlos Santana
level.
Like if you don't like Carlos Santana,
something's fucking wrong with you,
man.
You got it.
You got your own problems.
You know it's not Carlos for sure.
You know what I mean?
He didn't do nothing to you,
dude.
He's just out there playing guitar.
Shut the fuck up.
So what do you want to play this man?
I don't know.
I figured I had to bring a guitar because I do look at the Twitter.
Oh Dude,
raise.
It's harder now.
Now I'm now I'm going to ask,
talking to you man over now.
But we love talking to you.
Plus your music even more.
Well,
I can't even remember your,
I come here and we talk about like 90 different things and I leave and I'm like,
what did I even say?
Show man,
I don't even,
I don't even know what I said.
Well,
welcome to us to
let me,
uh,
me just play something off the new record
pain.
I've got shift brains,
got a hard low woman,
got a few friends.
I've got a cup of Nas hustles and got no man's soul.
Got a brand new show,
dig me out of this hole.
Got a whole lot of nothing.
Got a one trick pony.
She's
got a brand new staff,
got a payday slack
switch plate.
Make Khan stops from daughters.
Sag Man got a double standard.
I've got a woman's so fan and that's the way that happened.
I got a part time job,
got a full time hobby.
I get drug,
get the ball,
fall asleep from lead for the show.
You don't have where we I just live with the days
of vision is blurry.
My head has been climbing.
I got to me,
she hung up on this side,
got a hole in my heart,
got guilty of stealing,
got a battle as the Jamison.
It's hacky.
Denon got a pill for the pain,
got some trees for the following 25,000 Mau mass be go and I got no way.
No.
And got new ads,
got the clothes on my back,
got the sound that I'm singing
the Jama hammering it
down.
Beautiful.
Good,
good.
I'd say sorry that made sense today.
You know what I mean?
It's one of my favorite songs.
That's fucking bad ass man.
You know,
your,
your stuff has such a,
uh,
an Everlast feel to it now.
Like you really nailed your sound,
you know,
like nobody else could have played that song.
Like,
if I heard that song,
I would say,
well that's an Everlast song.
That's whatever last song.
It sounds like an Everlast song.
Do you know,
it makes it hard to write for other folks.
I got to keep that.
Yeah,
you got it right for yourself,
man.
It's to you,
you know,
you have this unique blend of having had all these life experiences in health
problems and being fucked over and be an up and down and man,
it just comes out in your music.
God Damn.
It comes out good.
Thank you man.
That was a,
that's how does a fat ass fucking style,
I say like this man since coming here and doing this,
it,
it did two things.
It made a lot of people who were like me playing acoustically and it also freed
me up.
Like I,
I've been doing a lot of shows like this now.
Aw Man,
that's beautiful to hear.
Couldn't be happier,
man.
It's been fun.
It's,
I really appreciate that sound.
I think there's something real intimate about a,
an acoustic set that a,
it's,
I don't want to say it's better,
but it's different.
You know?
For me it's,
it's,
it's great because everything starts that way.
If I sit in the room with,
you know,
this and maybe a drum machine,
maybe I'll come up with a beat and a guitar line,
but most of the time it's an acoustic guitar and me,
Oh,
you need man,
some of the greatest songs ever.
And when the lights go out,
I'll still be able to do it.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No,
it's beautiful,
man.
It's beautiful.
I got to say to Dan,
Dan at d Armand was listened to us.
Just think I was talking shit about it.
We just joke about what kinds of crazy shit your cats must've seen.
We like your baby.
We're friends,
we're buddies.
We love you.
We'll never,
we're not talking shit about you don't get over sensitive.
That's right.
It's like a comedy based podcast.
I mean she like,
yeah,
but people don't like being talked shit about it and she's just sensitive and
she's been on our show a bunch of times.
I just want them to know if even if I make fun,
it's always,
always with love.
They make fun of me anytime.
Thank you,
sir.
All right,
cool man.
It's really tough to find the angle without coming off like a,
like a dick,
but some was as nice as you.
I'm just going to go to the edges have been worn off man,
by this point.
You know,
in my twenties I was just raging asshole.
Well,
I remember meeting you,
you know what,
whatever many years ago it was and I was right away.
You seem like just a normal dude.
You know it's a weird thing when you listen to someone's music and you've known
him for so many years,
like I knew who you were when I was barely getting by.
You know when you were playing in my car.
I was driving around.
Jump Up.
You're in my car and shed when you know I was in my worry about at the 20th
anniversary.
Oh,
that's awesome.
With a bunch of remixes and acoustic fairs,
but you are one of those.
Yeah.
Not going to happen.
Actually,
the funny thing is I was just,
I was just doing an acoustic show and it's like this dude started saying jump
and then I was like,
I laughed it off at first and then he's like,
I realized he was serious.
I was like,
dude,
it ain't happening.
No dynamite hack.
The reversion of a Gen Ed.
Kind of cool.
If you could let me tell you something,
man.
I been cool.
If somebody else did that jump around is so God damn good.
Then I think it's almost like a disservice if you don't do it.
Even if you don't,
even if you've got to bring out more equipment,
jump around.
It's like you can't follow it as no more equipment.
When I show up the one they showed this to me and them since and at most of my
buddy or another guy on the acoustic guitar,
it's one of my favorite parts about Marcus Davis is a dude who fought in the
UFC.
It would always come out to jump around those when those bagpipes go off in the
beginning.
Oh God damn,
that was a good jam.
It does one,
it's still,
it stays in fuck.
Yeah.
Downloads like I'm amazed.
They're like,
oh yeah,
fuck yeah.
That's one of the all time greatest workout songs ever,
ever.
If you lifting weights and you listen to that song that get an extra rapids,
it's paying for that car outside.
I'm sure that's why I need to make that first begins the for vegans so he can do
it.
Occasionally eat eggs.
They find vegans aren't even allowed to eat eggs,
right?
I don't think so.
No.
That's not crazy.
That's an embryo,
but it's not.
It's only an embryo if it's been fertilized.
I used to think it was,
I used to think that every egg could become a chicken potential embryo.
Not even if they lay him every day.
Shit,
they delay the shit out of a main argument.
I'm just saying,
but I didn't know that it comes out like when it comes out,
there's no way you could ever be a baby.
Like it is just an egg and it's done.
Like even though she laid this egg that is a useless egg,
it will never be a baby chick.
When is it regular chicks then?
It has to be fertilized.
So they have one every day and a w when a male chicken comes in and lay some
Dick tour,
then there's a baby in that egg.
But until the male chicken does that,
she's just laying duds.
So if there's no many come along and eat the duds,
so there's no males around it and it's guaranteed just fucking dugged city.
Dud City.
Yeah,
and you separate them anyway because otherwise they peck each other's fucking
eyes out.
I was cocky,
a little animals.
Wow.
What's a chicken look tastes like that has been fertilized.
Is it even better?
Is there a name for it?
Like deluxe egg?
Uh,
no,
let's call Balut in the Philippines.
Um,
we used to serve it on fear factor and it was funny because my Phillip waited,
I got halfway big chiclet it's like a duck embryo and it's um,
it's cooked.
It's a half Co.
Well it's not,
it's not like solid cooked like,
but it's still like gooey inside.
But I mean they're eating the bones.
I mean,
you can see the little duck.
I mean we served people this,
but my Filipino friends are like,
oh,
that's [inaudible] that's my favorite.
Why don't I go get me on your [inaudible]?
The flooding part would have been if like,
just randomly that happened where one guy was on the show,
he's like,
oh my grandma used to make that all the time.
Yeah.
What would we would know?
Horse Penis.
Yes.
We would never see it.
Sort of a Filipino person.
Balut but we served it to a lot of other people.
It's hilarious.
Like the thing called a hundred year old eggs.
It's not really a hundred years old,
but it's a fermented ag.
They,
they,
they dig a hole and they put them in the ground for like weeks or months or some
shit like that.
The eggs turn black and they have like a jelly,
sort of a weird texture to them.
They're fucking disgusting.
But people pay money for them.
I think it's inexpensive.
Delicacy somewhere.
Yeah.
That's what I call tampons at girls.
Forget about,
you know,
sometimes they pushed like a tampon into far.
I caught a Balut pawn.
It was like,
some girls were like,
I had it in me for four days and started to smell and rod
and I'm like,
that's fucking girls.
Are you hanging out with you get a clean these girls up,
man.
These girls are lost.
If given up on life days,
you forgot something was inside you for four days.
I was,
uh,
dating this girl a long time ago and that was fingering her.
And I pulled out a piece of her tampon that she didn't know was in there and she
totally freaked out.
She was so embarrassed.
She's like,
I'm so embarrassed.
I'm like,
why?
Why would you be embarrassed?
I'm like,
you,
you got,
you know,
you have to put stuff in there.
So something got stuck at you didn't know.
Why is that embarrassing?
I don't understand why I said marriage is evolved as you Joe.
Wow.
I was only 21 I wasn't that involved back then.
Well,
look,
you sounded pretty evolved how you reacted at 20.
I've been,
I might have been like,
what the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this?
We're just come from having no baby
baby though.
You cleaned it and you're like,
what the fuck?
I mean,
I
would've,
I probably would've been a little weirded out by,
yeah.
Yeah.
Was it,
was it,
uh,
just clean or was it like,
yeah,
Ge,
she'd pulled it out.
No,
it was clean.
She had apparently pulled it out and we'll left a piece of it in there.
Broke off,
which was really dangerous for women.
Yeah.
Toxic shock.
I don't know what the fuck that,
I guess it's like,
it's bad.
Whatever it is to stay.
That's four days of leaving a tampon opinion.
It's what's going to get you that.
Brian,
how did you tell your friend?
How are you hanging out with Brian?
Word Fuck is wrong.
In junior high school,
girls were staying at the Fairmont.
It's just Dana DRM on port dean.
Dean is a really nice person.
I don't care what she does for a living.
She's always been a very pleasant person to be around.
I know.
You know people say like,
Oh,
you're just trying to fuck her.
No one's trying to fuck her.
We're all friends with her.
She's a great person,
a nice person,
and she's funny,
funny check.
I love her.
So she likes doing gang bangs.
Whatevs I missed out podcast right there in my life.
Why don't you guys do a podcast anymore?
We just,
we're just so a horrible,
like we'll be like,
hey,
let's do one a day and like,
okay,
should we have on and then we both,
this is a space out and we're just really bad.
We work weird together.
We're very spacey,
both of us.
He just shut each other off each other off.
Yeah.
Well,
you're doing too much.
Anyway,
man,
you're all fucking stressed out and we got to chill out and listen to some
Everlast music.
I have actually,
I've listened to his album more than I think any CD I've ever had ever because
it's always at my car and it's always a go to CD because it's,
it's good.
There's a lot of good songs on it.
I'm not just blowing smoke up your ass and being,
no,
it's beautiful man.
What else you got for us?
Oh,
I got one.
I got one here.
I'll play.
It's off.
My last album,
which actually I started this thing last week and I,
and I,
and I might have approached it wrong cause I was kind of angry when I did,
uh,
Sony Atv music group or something on Twitter.
You can find it on my timeline.
These guys,
like I have an album that I put out in 2008 that's not on iTunes for nobody
knows the reason why no to,
and it's like I'm trying to get,
these dudes are changing right now that you'll put this out in mumps called
loved Warren.
That goes to Whitey Ford.
It's like I did an independent,
like,
like deal with one of these publishing people and it just,
it's been kind of like,
how come it's on up?
We got to push this up.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There's a lot of shit.
It's also the album that has Folsom,
my Folsom prison cover on it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's just,
it's,
it's purely a red not,
it's not even red tape.
It's like just motherfuckers just saying aware.
So like last week I said I'd tweeted like,
hey everybody tweet these assholes about my record.
Uh,
you know,
it needs to be on iTunes.
And like apparently people got pretty nasty quickly,
but I got a response from somebody at the company saying at first they were
like,
oh that's real professional.
And I wrote him back like real professional.
I was like,
you guys are fucking me right now cause you don't have a record of mine up that
I'd put out,
you know,
four years ago.
And then they got back to me.
So I'm saying respectfully request these people to get my record up on that
Shit,
man.
That's fucked up.
Cause there's some,
there's one person in there apparently working on my behalf,
I can't remember their name at this time.
So we have an undercover operative in the,
in the opera and the operation at the moment,
you know,
but you know,
what does it just in competence is it then by the,
by by tribe called quest industry rule 4,080 which is record company.
People Are Shady.
This just is what it is.
That's what it is.
So the industry,
it's a diet.
I'm going the record up,
but this songs from it and this song I originally wrote when I saw like imagery
of like kids in Palestine throwing rocks at like,
you know,
Israeli,
like,
you know,
armored cars.
And you know,
it was Kinda just was like explored the mentality of the oppressed and how far
you will let yourself be oppressed and
started to come to the conclusion to songs about a lot more than just that
though.
It's,
it's about kind of like what could be going on here.
So,
you know what I mean?
So this costs don't in my hand.
Oh.
[inaudible]
stone.
We'll start a new
stones and
stones.
Stones.
Okay.
It's Jackie
that filed.
You can kill that man.
Fight.
We'll stones.
Hey.
Hey
Matt.
Right.
Well,
stones,
stones.
God Damn,
that's good.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
That was awesome that his dad is one of my new favorite songs,
man.
Now you sir,
that is fucking fence.
Album's called love Warren the ghost.
Whitey Ford,
Sony Atv Music Group.
Get that shit up on iTunes,
please.
Man.
When I was listening to that,
I was thinking,
I need to hear this shit again right away.
Here's a video for,
you know what I mean?
No,
I need to get it in my car on the way home,
man.
I need to figure out how to get it on my phone and get into my car.
I'm going to have to download that shit and I can't get it off iTunes.
That pisses me off that that bothers me.
Now he is a different version on iTunes.
Then with the rag,
I'm burdens got drums and shit.
God Damn,
that was good,
dude.
It's fine.
Ooh,
revolution.
That's a great song,
man.
That that has,
that has everything.
It has everything,
man.
That's right.
It's against the fucking,
the beat is fantastic too.
It's a very,
uh,
the,
the way you played it.
It was very unusual sound for like an acoustic song.
I'll beat up like a drum man.
It's kind of like my thing.
It's like I was learning,
I was learned.
I was taught and learn.
I was learning.
I was learning to how to,
how to,
how to strum the guitar.
I like to cheat this hand like a drum and I down up next to kick and a snare
kind of way.
My mind works,
you know?
Yeah.
When you were in the,
the,
the middle of the,
I don't
know any musical terms,
but to me when you were really going at it,
man,
it was like,
it was both a drum and it was almost like there was a beat to it as well as you
know,
here in the,
the actual sound of the cords.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh,
it's beautiful.
Beautiful.
The words are beautiful.
It's so inspiring,
man.
I have no musical talent at all.
So I always say this,
like music to me is like magic.
Like you're doing magic.
I quit the fuck you do it.
Like you're making all this crazy awesome noise.
You know what I mean?
It is to me it's like I'm so musically retarded that it is like a form of magic.
So inspirational man.
It's awesome man.
It's beautiful.
Um,
another one I'm playing now.
I'll fuck
always nice.
There's another one off that record and I'll just keep it in that theme in
front.
The moment
it
pickup truck
got Mac
swimming,
still got three to go.
Gotcha.
Broken wing
got mass.
These fucked up.
Changements
what's been sad?
Smile.
Wow.
Yeah.
Okay.
Killing it.
It's called anymore.
How's it really good?
And that was on the same album?
Yeah.
That song actually.
Uh,
uh,
I wrote
like the night my father died actually.
Wow.
Oddly enough though,
it's
other than a reference to him.
It's not that much about him,
but except for the feeling,
it mean,
you know,
it creates,
I think for me it's just about fucking everything up.
You know,
every day,
you know,
is that,
uh,
when you,
when you write,
do you try to do that a lot?
Do you like,
um,
write things that are not necessarily about what you're saying?
Yeah,
a lot of times you don't want to like,
you know,
I mean you'll lay out,
I'm sure it's the same even within comedy writing.
Lay out a certain amount of yourself within something and,
and,
you know,
use it in a con and you know,
and in context to make it something else.
Right,
right.
You know,
it'll,
it'll uh,
it'll be coming,
you know,
because the emotion is what we go after.
You're going right.
It's all about emotion.
So it's like you want to tap into an emotion and it's like,
I want to recreate that emotion.
I'm going to have to use a piece of it to do it.
But you don't want to necessarily ea trying to tap into it.
Yeah.
The music can do,
man,
music is such a weird feeling.
It does tell you like,
it really like changes the way your whole body feels like it.
Tangle and shit.
I'm really stoned too.
I feel like I'm trapped like in a hypnotized or something.
Right now.
You think somebody could talk you into something that's not as drop,
change the subject.
Yeah.
Well that's a,
that's a,
one of the things about cannabis,
cannabis and the connection with music.
You really,
uh,
you know,
I hate being that person that go,
dude,
you gotta try it.
You got to try it.
But if it wasn't for weed,
I really,
I think I would be missing out on a lot of the levels of enjoyment that are
possible because there's some levels of enjoyment when you're high.
And one of them is listen to music when you're high and you listen to like
comfortably numb,
you know,
you,
you hit some old school pink Floyd when you're high and you hear all the subtle
nuances to the song he never recognized before and it's just,
it overcomes you and a wave.
It's,
it's what I like to refer to as the highest common denominator.
You know,
it's like when we all hit that intelligent moment of like not too,
you know,
there's a lot of music that caters straightly to base nature and base.
Yeah.
And then there's that music that like really inspires to do what we're talking
about.
Like find that emotion,
find that thing and really accurately describe it somehow.
Or the next person says fuck me too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
How did you know that about me?
How did you,
how did you know how to say that about me?
Like when you do that in a song or a joke,
you know,
I mean half the reason the real belly laughs come from other fuckers are like,
oh,
I know exactly what he's talking about.
He's so fucking write about
you hit some certain lyrics and people just go,
oh,
that's my fucking song.
That's my song.
He's playing my song.
There's certain songs that become your song man.
Like you just want to hear the [inaudible].
They give you a feeling,
you know?
I mean,
I can remember being a kid like right out of high school and I was at a friend
of mine's house and a is having a little backyard party.
Everybody was laughing.
Everybody's having a good time.
It was like life had not gotten too complicated yet.
I was still like only 18 and sweet home.
Alabama came out and he had a little boombox and don't,
don't,
don't don't that fuckings
song.
Oh Man.
Oh,
right away.
It was like we were smiling and laughing and drinking beers and talking shit,
whatever sounds good.
I don't know the whole song.
I don't know.
That was a great gun.
Damn Song.
That's an all time classic.
I used to do one for snoop.
That was a
awesome,
that's hilarious.
You hang out with snoop a lot.
I mean,
I wouldn't say a lot because you know,
lives are lives and he's like dead.
One of them dudes that's just,
he's like Dana White,
man,
I'm fucking wake up in a different place every fucking day of his life.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I don't,
I can't,
I mean,
I love traveling and working.
There's a limit dude.
I gotta be at home,
I guess driving a car once in a while,
you know,
hit the hit the olive bar like I'm talking about,
y'all know.
No Ryan,
we've already discussed this with him being stupid at the Ralphs.
Yeah.
Ralphs or Gelson's sometimes has a nice foods too.
Yes.
Damn right.
Green Olives that you read a lot about them.
All about them.
Do with the kits.
Discussing what?
Fuck fucking you.
How about a little respect?
Get into them.
It tastes like black licorice vegetables.
Yeah.
I love it.
Sounds good.
Give me more.
Good for you.
Hard to grow to some places where they really didn't have much nutrients,
but they're growing these stupid olives.
Olives grow on the side of a dirty hill with no rain gas.
All the people in Greece and then the,
you have to like treat them before you eat them.
Unless your dog,
my dogs eat them right off the fucking ground.
They're constantly and,
and I'm like,
you creepy bitches.
And then they get diarrhea.
You know,
that doesn't happen to me.
Dogs eating olives,
no diarrhea when you eat olives.
Yeah,
yeah,
but I'm talking about like some shit on the ground when a dog eats all of that
they found on the ground,
you're not supposed to do that.
What gives you diarrhea?
You've got a problem.
Yeah.
Jimmy direct son
said,
can it be something you're going to store it in the bank for later as well?
He has two questions for you.
That's what I'm,
and the other one is,
do you believe in bigfoot
already said who killed biggie already.
We already did that one.
But do you believe in bigfoot is a good one?
Yeah.
The funny thing is I just watched an in depth show or one of these things called
a,
it's like fucking like about this show.
I'm like his history,
history channel or whatnot.
It's all about connecting like the ancient world would like aliens,
you know what I mean?
And one of their ancient aliens,
is that what it's called?
And one of them,
they're trying to say big foot is possibly some kind of hybrid fucking like I
bred alien creatures drops you and that he's traveling interdimensionally and
that's why we're never catching cause he's moving
through portals of time and space that we can't possibly understand.
Well,
could be,
fuck,
let's make a show.
Didn't this Guy Die?
The guy who like said he perpetrated the whole big foot thing and like they
found all these like crass and things he made to make floats and what am I wrong
about that?
Yeah.
There's,
there's more than one person.
First of all,
there's been a lot,
but like a big,
I remember a few years ago a guy died and they were like,
he says,
everything was a hoax.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's been people that have that checked out after that episode.
There have been people that have done hoaxes.
There's no question about it.
There's been a lot.
But if there's not one guy,
if there have been hoaxes,
there've been hoaxes all over the fucking country and all over the Pacific
northwest.
There's a lot of shit in the Pacific northwest where it's like monkey canyon,
Ape Creek,
eight bluffs,
it's eight,
a lot of ape shit.
And one of the reasons is because the Pacific north west coast of the United
States has a long history of bigfoot sightings.
Is it people are highest fuck and they just see a bear walking on two legs.
It's possible.
Who the fuck knows?
Is it possible that there was a big primate that used to live in the woods?
That's possible to me.
Oh yeah,
that's fine.
I don't,
but I don't say it's impossible.
I'm just saying at this point,
really all the technology I phones this,
that nobody's caught a flick and the dude,
no,
we think that he was gonna Flick and if they do catch a flick it's like,
it's like fucking,
I just saw something on Yahoo or something just in the last couple of days about
a guy who says he caught the best picture ever of the loch ness monster.
And it was like a little kind of spine.
And even in the article it says,
it looks like it was a manatee or something.
And if the loch ness monster was real,
even if it was a real thing,
it wouldn't fuck with a like a great white shark.
Great White Shark,
which is a real thing,
is way crazier than this stupid loch ness monster.
The lochness monster is not killing anybody.
Jack Jack,
they had a shut down the beaches in Santa Barbara and less the ness.
Is that Dragon Joe?
It would if it the loch ness was a dragon that could actually has like fire,
like it just,
there's no been no evidence last dragon.
Okay.
Well what if it was a unicorn?
But my point is too much of that game of Thrones,
man.
That's what it's greatest show of all time.
It's up there.
I haven't,
I haven't tied with,
right.
See,
I only got into breaking band recently,
like right before this new season started.
Like Danny boy,
you'd always been trying to tell me.
That's a great show.
I got so bored on my last tour traveling.
I downloaded like all the seasons and they had like a special deal,
like 30 bucks and you get all four seasons.
I was like,
screw it.
I'll buy it.
I started watching it.
I did not stop for like six days watching breaking bad.
I have to get back to it cause I did it from this whole right tattoo.
My rights leave the whole time I did it.
Oh did Aaron Dellavedova grew Tattoo Holla at your boy?
He a while he was doing it.
I listened to or watched rather the whole first season I was like God damn this
is,
it gives better do this and he hasn't.
They haven't let me down yet.
Like I'm waiting for the like it's,
it's,
it's nice.
It's a good show.
What is his name?
Bryan Cranston.
Is that his name?
The lead actor?
Yeah,
I think so.
God Damn that guy.
The dude who plays is the young,
the younger dude was in one of my videos
many years ago.
White trash.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
It's that dude.
What's his,
what's his real name?
I forget
Chatham over on the studio the other day.
I see it with naughty show but at the last second his manager said that he can't
do it.
So he just had to sit here.
Yeah.
Why does he make,
cause he's in some kind of bullying campaign so he's not allowed to do any adult
themed podcast until it like,
cause it's like for the kids and stuff so he's not going to sound weird.
Contractor is bullying you have to do with sex.
Aaron something or Aaron's.
Isn't it weird how they like they can decide what your personality should be
like.
They can decide what you attach.
If the games,
when he was in one of my videos,
he played a truck driver.
Yeah.
White trash.
Beautiful.
That's the video.
Oh that's awesome.
Jesse sniffing fucking math in there dude.
Yeah,
that's a unusual show.
I've heard the wire is really awesome too,
but I know,
I mean but that show's over,
you know that might be the best cop show ever.
Never watched it.
I got washed like a couple episodes and apparently it gets really good.
I didn't give it a chance.
The first two seasons I kick off really hard and then they go off into this
other tangent where they almost lost me at that time.
Like where they went off to a whole different part of the city and like did it
hold new store and he kind of like almost,
it felt like they were scrapping the whole earlier shit,
but it all kind of comes around into a circle and it was one of the best endings
I think I've ever seen him.
I won't tell you.
I'm just saying it ends well.
It like,
it doesn't leave you like,
ah,
it's like,
oh,
it felt like a complete project.
All right,
I'm going to have to get to it now.
Goddammit.
It's good.
Everybody says you have to wires going to have to get a chance.
Great.
I uh,
I just loved that they can do shit like what they can do with game of Thrones
now.
I mean,
you could make like incredible special effects for a fraction of what it used to
cost and they can do it with like regular computers now.
I should Johnny Cash his hand in my video,
not even shake his hand.
I gave him a pound like Papa.
Really?
Oh yeah.
And the Folsom prison video we got probably when I made that song I like,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm like serious about shit.
Can we see that?
I went to,
uh,
I went to Nashville and met with his son just to be like,
look,
are y'all cool with this?
Cause I was mixing it with hip hop,
with the Cypress Hill beat.
Right.
And like on,
on the,
on the version that's on the record.
So I wanted to be,
you know,
respectful as I could to,
Johnny Cash is legacy.
So I took it to them and I was like,
Yo,
you liked sewing.
Loved it.
And then when I was thinking of ideas to do the video,
we came across the stuff that I had known about it,
but I'd forgotten about it.
They had just released this DVD box set of the Johnny Cash variety show.
And so I bought it and started watching it.
I was like,
how great would it be if I was on the Johnny Cash show and there it was it just
behind you that
like he had his own,
he had like a variety show and like
they let us use the footage,
man.
They liked it.
I mean they,
that's something they could have easily been like,
hell no,
you can't use
that.
They,
I mean,
that's so awesome.
Look at that.
I like the style of the show would use,
you know what I mean?
It was like,
you know,
but the point is like you were talking about how cheaply you can do some of this
stuff,
man.
It really didn't cost that much at all because the technology's there,
you know?
Did you,
when you have loved to been able to perform for a crowd like that,
a real crowd like that and just below that,
the very end is me and him sitting next to each other and he,
and he gives me a pound.
I've always felt like,
what would it be like to be able to go back to the 1950s and do stand up and
just fucked their brains up sideways?
They would have no idea what you're doing.
They'd be like,
what is this guy saying?
What?
What are you talking about?
Just cursing.
You'd be,
yeah.
She imagined going up and that doing that was,
did you imagine if you did jump around in front of the 1950s cra?
Oh,
that is awesome.
it up.
Do that.
I Dunno.
I sat next to a dude.
I sat next to a dude and gave him what he was wearing,
a black jacket and gave him a pound and the next,
and you know is Johnny Cash.
Give me a pound back,
man.
That shit was crazy.
That's cool.
Wow.
That looks good.
And some Forrest Gump.
What it was,
it was like,
let's get on some Forrest Gump type shit and that's how amazing.
Jump onto the old Johnny Cash show.
What do you think I think would happen if you went from a 1950s crowd and did
jump around,
do you think?
Do you think there'd be able to take a look at it?
You like you were bat shit crazy man.
Like back in the futures.
No hip hop.
Okay,
so there was no amalgamation of hip hop.
There was no,
what the fuck?
You guys were doing bagpipes and shit and it was all rowdy.
Just look at you like you were working them alien,
I'm sure.
But they'd be frightened by the sounds that the song made.
First of all,
if there we'd find that frightening.
Just the way you're barking out the lyrics.
I'm the cream of the crop and be like,
what the fuck?
They didn't know that there was no bragging music back then.
No.
It's like the leader of the pack.
You imagine you come along with jump around.
God Damn.
It's funny how to culture just sort of evolves and changes and it's hard to
imagine it ever going back to where it was in the fifties or the clothes they
wore in the seventies or any of that shit.
So it's never going to happen.
But you could see where back then that was what was up.
That's what was up.
You could see it all laid out.
You can see it all moving forward.
We're just tired of the old shit.
We need something new,
gets more and more complicated.
What a,
what did we live in?
A fucking weird amaze of humanity,
man.
Human beings are the wackiest motherfuckers of all time.
There's
broken machines out there,
man.
He's no manuals.
Everybody's gets a Ferrari with no fucking owner's manual or I'll just grind the
gears are running into the trees,
you know,
it's not,
we do not figuring out how to use the mind correctly.
You've got another one for us.
I got as many as you need,
man.
I've,
I do this.
I know.
You'd be like,
dude,
I'd be like,
Joe,
you got another joke for me?
Um,
what I'm trying to think.
What's the play here?
Do you do any other kind of covers?
I can really butcher some bill withers though.
This is really bad and I bad guitar playing,
but I liked this song.
I'll play it since you want to cover it now.
[inaudible]
hey,
hey.
Hey.
Used to lift
her
fees.
Watch it while no spank him.
File p trap.
No,
go home and I don't have grandma and them.
When I get to heaven,
our little fog.
Hey,
hey.
That was awesome shit.
You know,
that's one of my heroes.
Wow,
that's beautiful man.
You know you were saying you've know 20th his songs like ain't no sunshine.
Lovely Day then he's,
to me,
that is the shit bill withers.
You ain't seen it.
You should check out still bill.
Yeah.
It's a documentary about him.
It's really good.
Is he still alive?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but he don't,
he he,
he has a studio at his house.
He makes music and lacks it away.
You don't release it?
Nothing dude.
He just makes music.
Oh Wow.
He just,
he's just on some fuck,
fuck the music business.
Wow.
That's great.
What about all the people that would love to hear it?
I don't know.
I didn't,
I,
you know,
I got to rewatch it.
But I remember it because I've watched,
you know,
I watched it on the bus where you get high and watch it for a little while
watching a little while.
But it's like,
you know,
they taught his daughter's in the business,
I think he's just,
I mean his songs,
I'm sure his catalog makes a lot of money,
man.
That crazy.
Cause you hear his songs everywhere.
Every movies that use me song and ain't no sunshine and lovely day and ain't no
sunshine.
Who is he and what is he to you?
A man with pass try to stare me down.
But when he looked at you,
you at the ground,
you know what I mean?
Every woo everywhere.
Grandma's hands.
That's a classic.
He's got a song about a Vietnam veteran called,
I can't write lefthanded by the guy who lost his leg,
his right arm.
Wow.
In the war.
And he can write lefthanded crazy deep songs.
I liked that.
Like,
you know,
there's,
there's all the hip hop heroes I have.
And then there's like,
you know,
cats like bill withers,
Neil Young.
Yeah.
Tom Weights.
Those are the cats like on the songwriting side of things that,
you know,
tickle my fancy.
Yeah.
Neil young has written some pretty intense lyrics.
I was a,
he's a good dude.
I was working at a concert venue when Neil young was playing there and a riot
broke out.
They had a shut the show down.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
It was in the 80s.
There was a,
a lawn area.
It was called Great Woods and Mansfield,
Massachusetts,
I think.
I know.
Great Woods.
And uh,
there's uh,
the area that's like covered by like a structure.
Yeah.
Called them sheds shed.
And then there's a back area where it's like the amphitheaters.
Yes.
What they aren't yet.
Yeah.
And the grassy area,
they started fires.
People are cold and so they,
uh,
they lit things on fire and they stay in,
in the,
the security came over and told him they got to put the fire out and next thing
you know,
all hell broke loose and it was crazy and they shut the show down.
Wow.
Fuck if people,
they were lighting the fires,
they were like,
let's just start a bonfire,
you know,
here in the lawn.
And he's always wanting to have the fire,
you know,
they were just too many people that were fucked up too.
That's funny.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was interesting.
But it was,
I getting to see him on stage from like really close up.
I was like 19 and I had that Gig is a,
it's a weird thing for a young kid to see someone that they've seen like in
movies or on the unheard on a record and then they'll go like right there.
Like he's the right there.
It's a strange thing for young people to really dig new young man.
He's,
you know,
my father was big on Neil Young,
so like it's one of the things is like when you're young and you hear this music
and you,
you kind of just rejected on general principle cause it's your parents music,
right?
Then 20 years later you reexamine it and you're like,
wow man,
I know all these songs and they're really good.
Yeah.
That's kind of where all that comes from.
I had a good memory for the music.
Yeah.
There was a lot of songs that I had to go,
a lot of music that I had to go back to.
Um,
what is that?
Listening to the time.
Slowly turning.
Who sings that?
Okay.
Gosh.
Show heart ache away.
Moody,
Blues,
Blues.
My parents had that and I fucking didn't like it because my stepfather was
always playing it.
I'm like,
the Shit's annoying.
I want to play some kiss.
Right.
I couldn't get into it.
I was like,
that's his old man whacked music,
you know?
But,
uh,
as I got older,
I,
you know,
would listen to like a Moody Blues Song called Mike.
God,
that's a fucking masterpiece.
A holy shit.
Moody Blues don't get any respect.
Nobody is like,
Oh,
a huge Moody Blues Fan.
Yeah,
that's right.
It doesn't come up.
Pull that song up.
Just the beginning part of it,
because this,
this is a,
it's a beautiful song,
man.
And I couldn't,
I couldn't appreciate it.
Um,
story of your eyes.
Is that it?
Don't worry.
I'm not a big story by story.
The biggest story in your eyes.
Moody Blues.
I was never a big muddy boots.
It's not even nothing.
I don't like them.
I honestly,
I,
I barely recognize the song you sang me.
This is,
I bet you heard it.
You've heard this.
I've definitely heard that.
Oh fuck yeah.
This is pre internet pitches.
Can
you feel this?
And I didn't do it all,
man.
Okay.
Hey,
that's,
that's music.
You know what I mean?
I love that.
You know what I love about that Song,
man?
First of all,
that dude must've got a mountain of pussy from singing that song.
Right?
I mean,
I want to fuck,
I'm just,
and I'm a guy.
Years later kind of reminds me also like blue are some blue oyster cult.
Yeah.
I was never big on,
Oh,
I love that song,
man.
Story in your eyes.
Oh,
ain't one of the reasons why I love it is wired.
Some dudes love old cars,
you know?
It's not just a song to me.
It's like a little historic ride course.
Yeah.
When I listen to Jimi Hendrix,
when I listen to Voodoo child,
it's not a song to me.
It's a historic ride.
I'm going to go,
I'm gonna go on and on a ride or as a dead man,
and he's rocking the shit out of my car on the two 10 I'm driving in my car.
And the dude who's been dead simultaneously transporting you to probably the
first time in your life where you heard that?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I always associated one of the reasons why I like classic rock so much.
It's like that's what I associate with that Leonard Skinner Song while we're all
at a barbecue,
like right out of high school.
Like party.
Yeah.
It's fun.
Fun Music.
Absolutely.
Jimi Hendrix man,
listening to that Shit in 2012 he's dead for decades,
but all you have to do is find that shit on your thing.
Press play.
Brown,
Bold Paul.
Oh No.
I don't know.
That's all I used to know it.
I used to know what Jimmy Henderson and I can't for the life of me.
Can't remember it.
Yeah,
I know a little bit.
Yeah.
That's one of the things,
one of the things you pull out for like barbecues or beach fire pits and he
added effect of Your Voice.
Is there an interesting with dudes like Hendrix is like this certain iconic
figures.
Yeah,
like James Dean and Hendrix and Morrison,
you know,
there's like,
they,
they had an impact and then there are in the picture forever during the picture
forever.
You're never getting away from Jimi Hendrix if there's a guitar,
if someone's talking about guitar,
if you know,
if you want to use a sample,
one of my favorite songs ever is someone made a mash up of 99 problems with
Voodoo child.
It's fucking sensational.
So it's hard to fuck with because you got Jay z,
you know,
singing 99 problems,
which is a great song.
And then you got Jimmy Hendrix playing the Voodoo child soundtrack over it.
Oh,
that dude's,
but isn't it that certain dudes like there's certain parts of society where if
you,
you have an immense amount of success and then die young,
you're just in your,
in the vernacular forever.
You're,
you're,
you're one of the characters that guessing,
but most of the also not just the success
those people have had.
I mean like,
um,
there was an impact like,
no,
nothing sounded like Jimi Hendrix before Jimmy was right.
Because I mean,
even the guys at the time,
like Clapton and,
and Keith Richards and all these dudes were like,
jaw dropped.
Like what the eff,
this dude's ruining it for everybody.
You know,
that kind of thing.
Janis Joplin,
you know,
then nobody had seen a white girl saying that with that kind of just angry,
they,
there was at that moment,
a lot of,
you know,
what had like,
that era is like basically nothing.
The only thing new in the last 30 years,
truly new in music was hip hop.
And even that was recycled old stuff,
but it was just the delivery of it that was new.
You know what I mean?
Everything else is,
is a recycling of blues,
music,
jazz music,
classical music.
It's all recycled.
You know,
the Beatles did everything classical to,
there's no trick that's been done at the Beatles.
Pride didn't pull off already.
You know,
with only eight tracks at their availability.
Wildcats.
Today I have 5,000 tracks work.
What do you mean when you say tracks?
Like what did I know what that track in their day like to,
to have more than eight things like on separate were the quality of recording
depends a lot of times on how much you can separate the individual instruments
and deal with their balance and their,
you know,
you know the cues of them and,
and getting each individual sounding sharp and having what we call a shelf,
which means all sounds are audible,
but they all occupied different spaces.
You know what I mean?
Like each instrument is equal and feels you feel the weight the way they should,
but they have different shelves.
So if you looked at it on here with them separately,
the things that when you were high,
all of a sudden that you thought were all together that you can find the
separation in.
That's from multitrack recording and fucking being able to have those things in.
Otherwise you had to do everything like and what they call it.
They used to,
I mean and the Beatles made records with led had orchestrations in the middle of
them.
I mean so they were like bouncing seven tracks down to one track,
putting all their like so they were mixing while they were doing other things.
It's,
it's bananas.
When you think about what they pulled off,
making records with the technology that was available to them compared to like
now it would almost be like,
oh that's easy stuff.
Wow.
Back then it was like you had dad to invent ways to do what they were doing
literally every day.
Wow.
See a lot of musicians had to do that with their pedals and effects.
Jimi Hendrix was always had guy around and him probably told them with things
like how can we make this pedal sound different or this,
you know,
cause there was no mass marketed,
crybaby pedals and you know all that shit.
People made their own shit basically.
Wow.
What a crazy,
it's crazy.
When you think about how much it radically changed,
like in the,
in the 60s when that came along from the 50s like what two different errors,
I mean have ever been separated by that much change.
The fifties the sixties I mean that,
that is a really strange time throughout human history.
Drugs came into play,
man.
I'm telling you in a major way.
Fuck yeah,
that's exactly what Alex and cocaine,
Lsd,
when it was illegal,
no one knew.
Meanwhile everybody was taken.
Everyone from Steve Jobs to scientists and professors.
It's changed my life.
I wouldn't be,
I wouldn't recommend it to somebody like at my stage of life to do it,
but when I did it,
it benefited me.
Good trips,
bad trips,
all that shit.
Like made my mind a stronger thing.
Yeah.
I also have homies that are,
what are the one of the,
you know,
there was a gang of us and there's also a couple of them that are still kind of
fucked up,
you know,
little off.
But what happened to him?
Oh yeah.
You know,
back in the day,
he's one,
he's the guy.
We always call him the guy that never came back.
That's the guy that never came back.
He stayed pink Floyd at a song about that and the guy,
the original guy.
Yeah.
That's a scary thing.
But I was wondering,
so maybe he's just,
can't fucking swim.
Get back over here,
bitch.
Yeah.
Get your mental swimming together.
No matter if it's possible that he just gave up.
Well,
some people aren't prepared.
I mean Lsd,
I remember.
And if there's any physicists out there or doctors didn't know different,
I,
I vaguely remember we read about it.
We were like looked it up and like that basically by the actual l 25 drug that
you take is gone.
By the time you're getting hallucinations,
it's like it triggers something in your mind,
like a gland or something in your,
in your mind that activates basically all the electrical outlets of your mind or
just kind of,
instead of being shut down,
opens it all up.
So basically you ain't hallucinate and nothing that's not already in your brain.
You're not making it.
That's acid basically.
Wow.
I didn't know that,
that I could be wrong,
but I,
you know,
I took a lot of it when I was young,
but you know,
it was like,
you know,
uh,
I was also told once it's in comparison like to supposedly,
and again if this is ignorance that I'm spouting,
I heard it somewhere else in number repeating it.
So I am ignorant for saying it,
but I usually have a pretty good sense for what makes sense and what can be
true.
You know what I mean?
And then I've heard of swamis that cut the bottom of their tongues so they can
swallow their tongues.
And the reason supposedly for that is there was apparently some gland behind you
like you know,
behind this area inside your passage where they can reach up with their tongue
supposedly and touch it.
I just have a blast and it,
and he creates the same chemical effect,
touch,
hallucinate.
So they cut their time.
It could be,
I'm,
I apologize for ignorance if it's ignorance,
but a I'm crazy.
I've heard you've never,
I've heard of the swamis cutting their tongue.
Why else would they cut it?
If not to swallow it.
Let's look it up.
That car,
we got to go Google shit enough.
My brain just takes any information that says,
I'm going to say that for a podcast one day.
That seems like,
that seems like
thinking you would say when you're tripping.
Different other personality
could be.
That's why I said,
hey,
this might be ignorance.
I prequalified it so nobody can give me no shit.
That's creepy.
If that's true.
That's right.
I ain't going to court and swearing on that shit,
but I've,
I've,
I've heard this and read similar things,
but who knows who wrote those things?
You're absolutely right.
I could have been completely high.
I had been reading like the guy next to me scribbling.
Oh God,
this is a toe.
I found a terrible thing.
It was a tongue cutting ritual that we're women pot cutoff.
Uh,
their tongue.
They cut off part of their tongue to honor a politician.
Awesome.
Do you know what I understand is the part of your tongue that keeps it attach
that little string underneath your tongue is what they cut?
No,
this,
this woman actually had surgery to cut off her fucking a piece of her tongue so
she couldn't talk.
Awesome.
Wow.
Was there a good reason?
There's no good reason.
She'd have to be crazy as fuck.
Yeah.
It's like that episode of the twilight zone where the guy bets him,
he can't talk for a year or something and then he like comes in and he's like,
I got to renege on the bed man.
Okay.
And the guy cut his tongue out.
Oh.
Oh Wow.
This is the,
this,
I shouldn't be reading this.
This woman was trying to get a job that pays $45,045 a month and she was trying
to cut her tongue.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Fuck is wrong with me.
Well Swami Swami swelling anytime maybe I hallucinated that whole thing man.
Yeah,
these are all dudes cutting their tongue off cause it sucks.
You know,
tongue swallowing,
cut his tongue out.
This guy cut his tongue.
Swallowing,
tongue,
swallowing,
Google that one because
Butthole,
I found that one.
Oh is that really something that came up?
He adds butthole to everything
nowadays.
You know,
you put a couple of words in there in a whole list of shit comes up.
It's like,
is this what you were looking for is like some crazy things happening.
Me Magic.
Okay.
So,
okay,
so now what Swami is attached to a swollen tongue swallowing.
Well a tongue glass eating razorblades.
Let's see,
I think,
cause I should know if this is true or not use or something cut Tom cutting as
similar to what you've seen.
The amazing Jonathan Do.
He uses a uh,
no,
this is different.
This is like a stunt that people do like they call it Swami
and there's an association there.
I'm guaranteeing it.
I believe you.
And it's not a radical feminist one.
Cut your tongue,
swallow it.
This acid is hungry for tongues.
What page of that?
Yeah,
I'm not finding anything there,
but um,
there is a gland in the middle of your brain called the pineal gland,
but I don't think you can reach it with your tongue.
That is the gland that supposedly is the third eye.
That's what they taught me.
Well that's the Glen I'm referring to and I see,
I mean,
so some of my shit,
I'm telling you.
Yeah,
to close looking,
keep looking because I'm telling you there's going to be something that I make
things up
unless they're really good.
Maybe I should hold Swami wrong.
I Suppose Swami some Alami let's say Swami third eye tongue.
See the a band.
It should be
third I tongue.
Swami.
Yeah,
Swami time.
Swami,
have you ever thought about doing anything other than music?
Like if you see like Mark Mcgrath hosting some celebrity show Sudan,
does that make you go with the I wouldn't do that.
No we didn't.
I mean like,
and I know mark,
I've known him a long time man,
but it makes total sense for a dude like him.
Like his personality is kind of built for those,
you know,
he's one of like,
I used to something like that.
Do you even you had ever even his,
even the way he performs in a band is key.
You know,
it's kind of caters to that kind of entertainment,
you know what I mean?
It's like very,
he's,
you know,
he's wants to entertain.
When you see like Justin Timberlake doing movies and you see a lot of rappers
have done movies,
do you ever think about doing any acting or the other guys did that a long time
ago?
It's not my thing.
I think if you're good at it,
do it.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I mean,
God knows we wouldn't have,
you know,
Mark Walberg is a pretty good actor,
man.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's very good actually.
I mean,
so we wouldn't have known that by his rap career though.
You know what I mean?
So go do what makes you feel good,
man.
Tupac was an amazing actor.
Yeah.
I just always wanted to know if you would personally,
I'm,
I'm in my,
I was like,
you know,
the older I get,
I think about,
you know,
maybe you know,
some youngsters and you'll get some produce,
some younger acts or something.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
That's,
you know,
still music,
you know?
Yeah.
Right.
Stick with what you love.
That doesn't mean bombard me with demos either.
Please.
Oh do you get a lot of that?
Nah,
I called people that people handed.
I don't ever,
you know,
I mean I try to give things respectful looks.
If something about it intrigues me,
but if you just start spamming me with shit,
I just block you.
The worst thing ever is when people want you to read
the scripts like pitch.
Do you know how long that takes to read a script?
So fucking does 110 pages of this bitch.
You're going to read this whole thing that's a,
that's like asking me the road down.
If the low down,
you know I'm not a script reader.
What am I doing here?
The fuck man.
We know.
What do you want us later swim past the breakers and watched the world die with
me and with my haircut.
Where you're at right now,
right?
You are?
What was that band?
I don't know.
Was it everquest?
No,
whatever.
Cause that band Santa Monica.
Oh everyone clear.
Ever clear?
You do.
You look like the Everclear guy
but,
but that dude is like you.
If you had aids with that,
that that guy having like a similar named at the time.
Like,
cause it was Kinda like weird that there was all these like ever things you
know,
did you ever beat,
you should threaten that car will ever clearly no rape on him.
It's very famous liquor.
It's weird that they would pick Everclear.
Is there a name because he's another one evergreen.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Like I got a call one day speaking to Neil Young,
we were talking about him earlier.
I got a call one day.
Like my buddy was like,
Yo man,
you're playing at the forum men with Neil Young.
I was like,
what I am.
Hey,
I'm in home dog.
I'm not playing at the forum and Julio and what the hell you're talking about?
Uh,
this was on my laptop and I Google it and there's some band called Evergreen.
I'm like,
this is my friend calling me by the way.
can you fucking read man?
But that was kind of like,
Yo,
they hadn't been,
I mean I've been around 20 some odd years,
man.
Come on now.
It's weird though.
It's all right.
Cause it is a different name.
[inaudible] stole it from a fucking boxing glove,
man.
I'm going
to write the name was Eric rocks everlasting and then uh,
you know,
it was like my,
he rocky was my original like kind of rap name and just kind of short and do one
day.
I was like Everlast fuck it.
It's amazing how my,
and back then not knowing copyright laws or anything like that,
I was like,
I already got a fucking logo.
I really kind of thought that I was like 17.
I was like,
yeah,
I already got a fucking logo.
I'll just steal that though.
I didn't really think about it.
Was there anybody else trying to be never ever last?
No.
It seems like a good name.
He seems like a name like that.
Somebody else might want to swipe.
There's like a Dj that calls himself Everlast which really I find funny.
Really?
Yeah.
Wait,
why do I feel like I met this dude?
Oh No.
But it's kind of,
it's kind of a jerk off move.
That's the one that would probably piss me off.
I like evergreen a Everclear.
Nah,
I feel like Tj Everlast get the fuck off my nut sack man.
Get the fuck off my nut sack man.
That's fucked up.
Yeah,
I met this dude.
I,
I'm pretty sure I met him and meet him again and give him a little smack.
Give him a little smack like,
hey,
what have you met a dude?
And he's like,
Yo man,
I'm,
I'm a a fro Rogan man.
I'm a comedian dude.
Gj Everlast music.
He's on my space when tight that sees on mice,
mice space.
Dude,
I've even looked at my face.
I'm like six years weird.
My space is still there though.
I still have one on my,
but my manager is the only people who even go near probably.
But how strange it really stop and think about the fact that it's still there
and nobody goes there anymore.
Like what did they do to fuck it up so bad?
And they kind of set it all off.
It's like,
yeah,
they set it all off.
They may Dane Cook if it wasn't for my space,
didn't mean my speed was literally,
there was an article I will never forget it was in people magazine is they're
responsible for Tila Tequila.
Oh yeah.
They jumped her fuck off.
Thank God she's here for us now,
man.
She had a provider's entertainment and the first female Juggalos whatever.
Yeah,
it's a,
my space was the shit at one point in time for for clubs like to want to
promote.
Like we had a Gig,
he would go on my space.
That's how you'd promote your gag.
Good luck now bitch.
Joey Dee has stopped using it.
Even when Joey Dee has stopped using my expat to silver because that's how he
was writing his blogs.
Writing them all on my space.
Yeah,
I don't,
I have not literally even looked at it.
I haven't even thought to look at it and I'm like,
I wonder what,
it's just an,
it's an ancient thing.
To me it is,
but it's so amazing that it happened so fast.
It was within a couple of years.
It was,
it was giant.
Everybody was using it and
it was like,
Facebook's better fuck this.
And they just all left my own,
my space.
It's still there.
Wow.
That's hilarious dude.
Well,
it's funny is my picture was like,
I had the same avatar for the longest time and then when I left my space I just
took myself out of the picture.
Like I used to be standing in front of this painting right here.
Oh.
And then I just took it
brides on here,
man.
Jenna Jamison.
Yeah.
It was a strange thing.
My space,
I don't know where takes off.
Everybody's on it and then it goes away.
And then Facebook and then Twitter.
The thing about it,
the crazy part is like fucking,
if you remember like Facebook really wasn't that big man.
Wow.
And then nothing will happen that changes these things like crazy world events
change these things.
I,
at least this is the my perception of it,
you know,
which is,
you already heard my swami story so I could be way off fuck off here,
but like if I remember correctly,
not too many people were messing with Facebook's until that Virginia Tech
shooting really?
And then like they started the news was like the guy has a Facebook page and
then it's like all of America.
I mean that's when Facebook was around,
people were messing with it,
but I'm talking about it didn't go nuts.
And so after that event
cut to Alex Jones going,
well what happened was Facebook engineer the shooting,
they got him,
it was a Manhattan project type event.
It was top,
top secret and they brought him out to the desert.
I'm not selling you that,
I'm just selling you that when you hear Facebook 4,000 times on every 24 hour
news network,
you get curious about it.
And people started looking and probably wanted to see the fucking disturb
fuckers page.
Maybe people want to see that kind of shit.
Then Twitter,
Twitter was on the bubble.
It was,
it was.
I'm not saying these things weren't around.
I'm talking about when did they crack and go fucking global.
Twitter was the fucking,
these little,
this fucking,
uh,
Arab spring
I heard friends stirs offices was in tower seven like,
like the office of Friendster was in tower seven when it went down or were,
you know,
dude,
yeah man.
I remember finding dudes in the news that like killed that one got by before I
even knew about that kind of shit.
Like Friendster was old when I first heard of it.
Yeah,
same here.
It's like compuserve.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Do you remember that?
The uh,
I think,
yeah.
Product.
Did you ever have an angel fire website?
No.
No,
but one of my homies went and like I was,
he came home in studio and had to grab something out of it is like email or
something and he fired up America at AOL.
I was like,
I heard that.
That's exactly what I heard.
You got mail.
I was like,
man,
it sounded just like that.
I was like,
man,
you're still on America Online.
That's crazy,
man.
I mean,
but you know,
says the guy with an earthlink address,
earthlink,
earthlink.
Dot Net I wonder who was the guy that did the voice for,
you've got mail.
I whenever it's probably not even a real human is probably cool to date.
That dude didn't have sex at that dude during the time of the AOL boom.
He'd probably had some fun things to say in bed.
Did you think he was doing that?
I was just doing that voice everywhere.
That was a shit.
I'm gonna fuck you in the end.
He was like Max head room.
Yeah.
Max head room.
Oh look career doing that for a while at a movie off his phone.
You've got mail,
you've got nail.
Do you remember when the dude would do something like kill somebody or something
and you would,
you could go to his myspace page and your point about like,
that's what like that Virginia Tech Shit did for fun cause it was all college
and all's they talked about,
I remember on the news was like the guy wrote his whole,
like this whole thing on his Facebook page and Facebook page and the logo was up
and that's when it went big.
Man,
I'm telling you one,
if you're right,
it makes sense.
Well,
I made sure,
certainly,
certainly helped,
certainly made people,
but I think Facebook offered what my space was already offering.
Just they did it way better.
They made it way less clunky.
It's just like they said on the thing too.
It's way more exclusive.
Yeah.
Well there's no glitter 10 times,
you know,
only 5,000 on it.
That'd be gotten out of control on my space tour.
It was like,
I have 400,000 friends.
Like not even famous people like,
you know what I mean?
Like regular people that go on up there on these trolls for more friends.
And,
uh,
it's like,
I don't care.
I don't even look at my Facebook really.
You know,
I'll be honest,
when I started using my Facebook fan page,
I post my shows on it and I look at it,
but I don't,
I don't get into a lot of exchanges with people like Dana's philosophy,
like I was talking and he's like,
man,
you want to be our big on the Twitter.
Just go at it with some of these fuckers.
I'm like,
man,
I ain't got the energy for that shape.
Somebody writes some dumb shit to me.
It's just like easy.
Let me go to your page right here.
Oh,
block.
You buy.
Yeah.
I don't need that in my life,
man.
I write blocked and retweet them or retweet to win.
Right.
Blocked.
It's gotta be funny,
Amy,
to retweet it.
If it's just like stupidity,
I'm not going to retweet it.
It's funny and it's bad.
I don't care if it's bad about me.
If it's funny,
I'll be like,
okay,
here you go.
I will do it.
Because I don't think people realize how stupid,
what they're riding sounds respond to it.
But then they just do it just to get it wrong.
I bet you're wrong.
I bet.
What happens is,
first of all,
I blocked him after I retweet them.
And then second of all,
when when you get the negativity back thrown at you by all these people think
you're an asshole for saying something stupid,
then you realize what it's like and you're like,
what the fuck am I doing causing problems in my life for no reason.
I did that to the Sony people and like I felt bad because like some people were
like,
why is it going to record online bags?
Bitch.
Hey Bitch.
Hey fuckers.
It's like,
Whoa,
whoa guys.
I'm just trying to get the record up.
Yeah,
you got to give a very specific instructions on how to attack.
Can just let them go.
Look down.
I didn't know.
I kind of called them Douche bags and I was like,
call these assholes until he's Douche bags.
We put my record.
I don't know.
Well it's my fault.
Yeah,
you started at Man.
Yeah.
So is the industry people man.
And you know,
if you're in the music industry,
in my opinion,
and this goes for anybody working for me,
that falls under this category,
gets the same description.
If you're in the music industry and you don't make music,
produce music,
record music,
or uh,
somehow puts your hands on music,
you are Leech and uh,
and uh,
uh,
parasite of,
of,
of cat proportions.
Has it always been like that though?
It's set up,
the game is set up,
the game is set up.
It's the own.
And not only are you a parasite,
but you're the only parent.
If you're in the music business and you don't make music,
you mean,
then you're living off another one organism.
So I'm not being even a dick when I call you a parasite.
But I'm saying what makes you the worst kind of parasite is you're the only
parasite that's figured out how to eat before the host organism
you day.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying.
Like they all are getting their money's the complete disproportion and by the
time it gets to the person who generated all the monies,
in most cases,
it's nothing.
You know,
that's why you see some of these sad stories of cats that should have it all and
don't cause by the time it got to them,
nobody helped him.
First of all,
you know,
if you're young and somebody hands you a ton of money,
I mean I'm surprised I'm alive.
The amount of money they handed me when I was young,
you know what I mean?
How does it work?
Um,
without collusion that they keep the rates so high amongst people I've had.
I don't know.
It's just cause the only excuse you get is,
is,
is that's how it's always been done.
Now I don't buy in to people.
I,
I'm,
you know,
I'm telling you I've been doing it long enough where I do it the way I want to
do it.
If I don't.
What were the options when you first started?
There was no other options.
You said you started before the Internet.
What was it?
What was it like when you,
we also used to sell records shall your own record.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying in general,
you moved a lot of units before the Internet.
You know what I mean?
If you had any kind of,
you know,
even if it was just so nice to him playing cat videos over there,
so there was more,
more money period.
Yeah.
Well I mean it's just like,
you know,
you had to,
if you wanted some music you had to buy it and bootlegging was like,
you know,
a guy on the block buys the record and two of his friends gets to the cassette,
tape it from him.
You know what I mean?
Right now it's like a guy on the block buys the download and 5,000 goes on some
site and 5,000 people get a copy of it.
You know what I mean?
That's so,
you know,
well even distribution is moving to a digital model,
so it's almost like you don't need that anymore with things like I tell him,
he still level record in my hands,
don't you know,
I like to have a CD in my hands and unfolded and look at it and that's just me.
That's the generation I come from.
Oh yeah.
I listened to,
I remember when we went to cds,
I missed her albums.
I used to love album artwork and that was a big part of the record.
There used to be a grammy category and I don't think it is anymore.
It used to be best album cover.
Yeah.
They don't even do that anymore.
I remember,
I remember teaching Sean's big bamboo.
It would open it up.
It was like a giant rolling paper.
It's fucking true.
Me Real actually rolled a joint comparable to the size of that paper.
I believe it.
Yeah.
Smoke.
I think he's still got the road which is like this
long and like that fat like in a frame thing and his house.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Big Bamboo was a classic.
And there was uh,
the,
the album cover itself as part of the whole experience.
What do you do?
Both that and they didn't have music videos though,
you know,
or rarely,
you rarely saw any,
any,
anything visual put to the music.
It was,
music was like a completely audio experience.
Internet killed the video star did it though.
Cause it Kinda expanded things too,
man.
It made like an opportunity to like this.
One of the coolest things about this Gig is being able to have guys like you and
we have this band,
honey honey came in and play and it's the coolest thing ever.
It would be like have a three person concert.
Yeah.
You know,
it's fun.
I like I that's,
you know,
I was like,
I gotta bring the guitar.
I know.
So this is the Internet though.
This is the same thing that can cause the same thing,
man.
I'm make a lot of my bread off and go with my,
you know,
my fans are loyal cats.
They buy my records,
they buy my downloads.
I mean I keep a steady stream.
You know,
I'm,
I'm not a hater,
but at the same time you realize it's just changing.
It's just changing and things are getting weird.
Like,
no,
it's not that it's changing.
Here's the thing is like
before the Internet,
I,
I guarantee you I was,
there is no record I would have ever made that wouldn't have moved at least a
couple hundred thousand units.
Right now on this last record,
I think I've moved about 50,000 you know what I mean?
That's completely independent.
I don't,
you know,
it's good,
good money.
I'm not tripping.
But what I'm saying is you're not going to tell me that those same other hundred
50 200,000 people ain't checking for me.
Right.
They're getting the record.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I figured for every one you sell,
four or five people are just taking it.
So you sound like your problem.
You're selling it on your own,
like out of your own websites.
I said No.
I mean,
I have a distributor with emi records,
but I owned my own master's.
I owned my entire label.
I mean,
they just helped me distribute my record.
So when it's,
when,
when you say they help you distributed,
that means physical record.
I mean otherwise,
like iTunes and all that I do,
you know,
you don't need even need a distributor anymore.
You just go to them.
It's available through them.
So when you say 50,000 you mean 50,000 people bought an actual CD albums.
Yeah,
actual album.
And then there's,
I mean,
but then a lot of people,
there's a,
I mean I can't even,
I don't even know the numbers on like people that just come in by individual or
two or three songs off the record,
you know?
And that's it.
So that confuses numbers too.
That's kind of cool though.
He could do that.
I'm not complaining at all,
but don't ever want anybody to get it twisted.
I live a real good life,
you know?
Like I said,
I'd like to meet that hedge fund fan superfan and ones that helped me
be super rich.
Say that it's going to take into place where he's been cloning babies.
Show you what's up,
you got to keep secrets.
I'm cool with that man.
You go with that.
Maybe
depends on what they do to the babies once they clone him,
I guess.
Yeah.
You know,
if they're just cloning babies,
I mean like bringing them to,
they're going to good homes.
I mean,
hey
everlasting in a mansion and the East Hamptons.
What?
Fuck,
where
the fuck do you get this place man
investment that I got.
There's something crazy about the people that made billions off the internet and
the beginning,
you know,
when the Internet dotcom boom was taken off,
people sold websites are crazy amounts of money and mark Cuban,
one of these guys and he's a billionaire from that.
Yeah.
He's managed to stick around though.
So He's,
he's smart.
He's a very nice guy too.
Very normal guy right down to earth guy.
Remember he was,
um,
he was evolved I think in some fight organization.
I think maybe he was involved in affliction in some way too.
And he had to HD net year and he put on the name of that reason.
It's access TV.
Those are the,
it's still his though.
It's partly his,
I think.
And Brian's see cresses and recorded a show for that channel.
It is for like a live show showing it a lot too.
Those are great.
Yeah.
They,
I don't know why they had to change the name.
I thought HD net was a great name and they're big on the fights man.
They have the MMA weekly and all that.
So what boss?
I love that show and yeah,
that's what I was going to say.
They're the best as far as like one channel that covers all sorts of different
fighting sports.
Like they have k one the smallest shows in little towns like really they're
doing naming me.
Oh yeah,
they'll put on,
did they go to like,
uh,
you know,
all these different small organizations at very few people have ever heard of
and they'll put on those fights and they'll put on all the best kickboxing too.
It's real hard to get good kickboxing in America.
It's only that access TV.
Nobody else even shows it.
You don't,
you can't see like the high level Moy Tai and high level kickboxing like k one
style.
It's the only them,
but the only ones providing it.
They always showed the dream shows and all that.
That is the one thing when I always tell people if there's one untapped market
in the sports entertainment world,
it's high level kickboxing.
Somebody has never capitalized on that.
While boxers are making fucking millions of dollars,
MMA fighters are making millions of dollars.
These kickboxers are still languishing and these mother fuckers are so exciting,
like real high level Moy Thai kickboxing,
it has not been exposed to the masses.
People don't realize how God damn exciting it is due.
It's kicking each other in the fucking legs and the head and flying elbows and
knees and shit like that is a crazy,
exciting sport.
Like Muay Thai is really exciting.
It's just hasn't been exposed to America correctly.
It's up a huge moneymaker just waiting to happen of UFC proportions.
If somebody,
some rich dudes,
some investment type character had the balls to put together some really high
level kickboxing and start showing that shit in America,
they would make mad loot because one of the things that everybody loves about
the UFC is that anything can happen,
but the other thing,
they love his knockouts,
people fucking loved knockouts.
They love submissions,
but when it comes to like what they would choose,
they choose to rather see somebody to get kicked in the face.
It's clarity.
It's something crazy about it.
When a dude just like the Donald Serone fight last weekend,
Donald's right Shawnee head kicks go lard.
And then as he's Ouab limb comes in with the fucking death blow and Kaos him on
the way down.
I mean that's what people want to say.
It wasn't mean tremendous,
tremendous.
That's,
that's not available in kickboxing,
unfortunately.
You can't hit a dude in the face while he's going down.
You know,
the referee was separate,
so you get a standing eight count,
which is actually kind of the worst way to fight.
It's actually like more dangerous to be allowed to recover.
You know,
it's better for the referee to come over and save.
You have to do punches you one or two more times than you to sort of get your
wits back and then get properly k the fuck out,
you know?
But in,
in k one kickboxing and in Moitai,
that's all.
That's all the standup fighting.
It's all kicking and punching.
It's all the woods.
Probably the most important shit or the most,
uh,
exciting shit to watch.
No one's ever really capitalized on it.
It's weird.
You know,
you don't give a fuck.
I do.
I love kickboxing,
man.
I'm still feeling the effects from earlier,
Diane.
I've been stuck on stupid for a while though.
That weed is no,
it's actually sitting here reflecting on the whole Swami thing and I'm like,
man,
I'm just going to get it today over this Swami.
No.
People are gonna be like,
we can never retarded shit.
Is that cutting her tongue in my brain?
What?
I hope somebody proves me right as all otherwise,
I'm like,
man,
that was a good hallucination because deep in like page five of Google,
you know,
a good hallucination of an explanation though,
man.
I was thinking of foster I lyric a good hallucination of an explanation.
Yeah.
Maybe you could just combine them in your head in some strange way.
I'm sure something like that happens.
If it's not coming up on Google,
we all know how reliable the Internet is.
I mean,
it's,
everything's on there.
And how do the beauty of podcasting is that people get to see,
talk a little shit and not be correct.
It's not edited.
It's like,
this is why I like you.
I don't have like,
you know a war room like laptop and in my n in front of me.
Yeah.
This is a manly laptop.
Look at that.
Yo,
man,
that's a Goddamn Shit.
Yo Man.
I thought she was gonna.
I thought that was a briefcase.
It runs on coal.
Think as a nuclear reactor.
You're in
the center of it.
Yeah.
This is,
we started using these because they support them and then runs on the board out
of the innocent.
It's slowly,
slowly tapping into your soul and it's been staring at me for a while,
dude.
It's isn't it?
The eyeballs are starting to the lady bug.
It's us in the future is what it is,
man.
That's what the alien is.
We know that's the future.
That's inevitable.
That's what we're going to look like.
Really.
If we used to look like monkeys and this is what we look like now,
that's next.
No doubt about it.
The atmosphere is going to road.
So we're going to have big black guys like permanent sunglasses and that's what
I'm thinking.
Permanent Sunglasses,
because we're going to deal with a hostile environment.
You're not going to really talk anymore.
So you have a giant head,
a little tiny slit of a mouth.
You're probably gonna get all your nutrients through fucking some cream you rub
on you or something.
It's probably not even going to have to eat anymore.
They're going to invent orgasm pills.
Your Dick's can shrink away to nothing.
So you'd be like that man in a suit.
It let's skinny thing.
You don't need your muscles because you're controlling the universe with your
brain.
You speaking telekinetically so you don't a language anymore outside of actual
information.
You can my jobs,
my job is obsolete then.
No,
I'm going to,
I'm a mentally telepathically sing to you.
Well that's what I think.
Um,
that's why I think the idea of simulation theory is,
is actually plausible and that simulation theory is like real legit scientist
have.
They've offered up the possibility that if someday someone created an artificial
reality,
some day someone created something that was a controlled,
it was something generated by a computer,
but it was undetectable from reality.
It seemed real.
Is it possible that they could get to that level someday?
And the reality is yes,
yes,
it is possible.
If the advent of technology and technological innovation keeps moving in the
same direction,
everything gets better.
So if you look from now to a thousand years from now or a thousand years ago,
you look at what we're capable of now and extrapolate what a thousand years from
now,
we're going to be capable artificial realities a given,
it's going to be easy.
So the idea is are we already there?
Are we already in that artificial reality is,
is it possibly matrix?
Is it possible that these aliens,
this is what we really look like dog,
but this is whack.
This is a stupid way to live.
Nobody's getting a dick sucked.
No one's car makes him cool noises.
Nobody could play some badass music.
Everything is is like evolved in telekinetic and everything is,
you know,
without sin over that.
But there's no whiskey.
There's this notion of Tongan,
no one farts on you,
you know,
don't unplug.
Yeah.
There may be.
This is why,
you know,
our life is so crazy.
Maybe this is why life is so chaotic and ridiculous and it would seem like the
type of being with the brain to build something like New York City would have
everything else completely wrapped up too.
I mean,
it takes an amazing amount of innovation,
thinking computation and construction and just just amazing amount of
sticktuitiveness to build something.
Build something like a New York City.
You would think an organism that can do that.
Well,
they got everything wired.
This whole thing is what they've,
they,
they're,
they're from the future.
They figured out the whole thing.
They look what they can do.
They can do impossible technical tasks.
Surely socially they would have it all together.
Surely they wouldn't be this crazy mix of hypocritical bullshit and pro fucking
propaganda on television and nonsense.
There's no way they would be that stupid if they,
how would they make satellites and B,
that's fucking stupid.
There's no way.
So the idea is that we are from an evolve time,
but it's boring.
So we've come here where Shit's fucking crazy and that's what makes it fun.
You could be having me hi tripping on the way home like,
well you know,
I've gotten shit about us.
One of those,
you know,
the whole universe could be under your fingernails,
pubic hair.
The real problem is,
is starting to be substantiated with science when they're,
they're doing,
you know,
these string theories guys and these quantum physicists guys where they're doing
technical computations when they're trying to figure out like the,
the nature of,
of the,
the actual matter itself.
One of the things they're finding is they're finding that there's mathematical
programs to it all.
There's,
there's things in this life follow mathematical computations.
They follow like an algorithm.
They fall.
The FIBONACCI sequence is like the way a person's face looks,
the way a tree grows.
Branches the way a sunflower seed,
it's all like mathematics in escapable mathematics.
And then they're finding more code in,
in,
in quantum theory,
they're finding like the,
the,
the smaller they're getting as far as like the,
the smaller things that they're looking at in the universe.
They're finding mathematical algorithms that you could clearly track like that
they met,
they've,
they've measured from the 1940.
It's like they know what they are like,
they know this actual program.
So it's,
it's,
it's not outside the realm of possibility that this might be an awesome
simulation.
That might be why it's so much fun.
Maybe.
Is this stuff that happens and you,
you,
uh,
like get really deep into in the isolation tank?
Yeah,
that's a problem.
The isolation tank is only about what is real because nothing's real once you
get in there.
Once you on there for though if you'd done it,
I've experimented similarly but not full up like,
you know,
like nighttime in my pool with my ears plugged into my eyes covered.
That's all growing.
That's all grove and everything.
But you need a real one.
You need one.
Yeah.
Everybody needs one.
It's one of the biggest injustices that people that are interested in thinking
and creating don't have one of these things.
Cause if you're in the simulated reality,
you're probably already laying in some sort of liquid.
So you're bringing yourself back almost to your assets.
If you're doing that or nothing is real and your,
your,
your consciousness has been downloaded into some sort of a gigantic computer.
Hmm.
That one's,
there's gotta be some kind of organic matter.
You think so.
Oh yeah.
Well what if I'm of what if technology is organic?
What if we just,
we think of it as in organic because we create it because we create a phone.
What if you look at it?
What if it's an actual life form that's independent of us,
but we have this weird symbiotic relationship with it where,
where are the method that it's evolving through and it is going from being a
fucking toaster.
Do you remember star Trek shirt on or something?
You're going to start talking about the Borg or something in a minute.
Well if you really stop and think about it,
we are,
we're connected to electricity.
We talked about that earlier,
but then we just the power,
but we would panic if the power goes out.
I panicked.
I don't have my phone.
I panic if my car doesn't work.
You're like,
Shit,
you,
we are already connected to certain aspects of technology.
I leave the house without my phone.
I feel pretty fucking naked.
I would rather walk out of the house with no shirt on than I would with no
phone.
You know,
I feel like,
I feel like less of a freak.
Wow.
My phone is more important to me than clothes.
Like I need,
I need to be able to talk to people.
Yeah.
It's strange.
It's not strange from out there in the wild.
What of my fuck fucking car breaks down?
What am I have to walk to a tow truck?
Where's the tow truck and what direction do I know?
Do I walk around naked and as people,
come on man,
Hey,
I need that fucking phone.
Actually in that scenario would have been naked.
It doesn't make any sense.
It'd be a good time for new song with uh,
we have by way five minutes.
Okay.
You got a song,
guys got time limits,
Huh?
Well,
at three hours we turn into a pumpkin.
Yeah,
it's bad for iTunes.
Something happens.
Oh,
no one more for you.
Okay.
Uh,
do this one's called long time.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] swears the older one
for the,
for the damage
was faithful.
Sad,
sad,
sad sack.
Spin down since
it's been lounge.
Same Sabz painful
spin,
spin lounge,
downtime.
Since I was grateful.
Dude.
Thank you very much man.
Anytime man,
thank you for coming here.
Anytime you,
you know you want to come back,
anytime you feel like playing some songs,
please just Holler at me.
That's what I did.
I said I'm ready.
Let's go.
Yeah,
it was beautiful,
man.
That's beautiful.
Thank you very much man.
Very rational phone.
When I first came on this motherfucker,
man,
I just quit.
My Twitter or guy just started,
restarted after quitting Twitter,
man.
You know what I mean?
And,
and there's like damn near 30,000 people on it now.
So you know,
that's all love from coming and a lot of it coming from your direction,
man.
So all that well listen man,
that's beautiful.
And every time you're on it,
man,
we appreciate the fuck out of it.
We get a million positive tweets already.
I'm looking at it right now.
My Twitter's blowing out.
People loved it.
They had a great fucking time as always.
Oh Gee.
Everlast can shake me out just to say,
oh yeah,
I got a bone to pick with you on your fans.
We have,
oh,
some mother fucking pictures on Instagram dog,
Nigga.
There's one and it's a minute.
I don't understand that.
Instagram,
everybody is like really into his pictures outside of like Twitter picture.
I don't get it.
I'll try to use it.
I'll try it.
You just set it up so it,
it's you.
When you,
when you,
when you put it on Instagram,
you hit one button and it'll,
it'll,
it'll go right to your Twitter.
Okay.
I'll hook it up there.
They're mad at you,
man.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry,
but,
and plus man,
it,
you know,
I got like 9,000 people on there.
I got like 300 pictures.
You got one and there's like 30,000 people.
All right.
I'll put some more,
I promise.
I folks,
I did sal.
Go follow me now.
Yeah,
please.
Oh Gee.
Ever last fall.
I'm on Twitter.
And now thanks to audible.com audible a our sponsor for the day.
If you're a,
you're interested in,
uh,
in checking out a free trial,
go to audible.com forward slash Joe and they give you 30 days for free.
So download a fuck load of cool ass songs or books rather.
Um,
uh,
books on audio,
audio,
books,
books on CD,
books on what?
He just downloads.
Turn them into CCS if you want.
I think Kenya,
can you turn him into cds or you can burn it to a CD,
right?
Yeah,
it is encrypted,
but you PR,
you can burn it to a CD.
Ken Burns and you did.
Okay.
I believe that's,
I mean I haven't done that in awhile,
but in these audible,
yeah,
audible is a,
it's an awesome service and there's so many fucking books there.
And like I said,
it's,
it's awesome for traffic.
Much like this podcast is good for when you're,
what happened.
See every time I get out of it says chat now.
You got a shot with bitches.
Yeah,
don't worry anything.
You don't write anything still game.
Are you sure it's Mike?
Yeah.
You are now trialing with Mike.
Let's see if Mike's,
if Dick ever been to olive garden,
ever been raped.
No,
don't do it.
Uh,
thanks to uh,
audible.com.
Go there.
audible.com forward slash Joe and get yourself 30 days of free trial and it's,
it's an awesome service.
Great books.
And uh,
like I said,
it's the best for traveling.
Really makes it interesting.
It makes me not want to park my car.
Thanks to onnit.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune,
new mood.
What's new mood bitches,
Serotonin,
boast,
boasting,
boosting and boosting.
It's um,
yeah,
five HTP and L.
Tryptofan it boosts your serotonin levels.
It actually makes you feel better.
It's called new mood.
Check it out.
Go to on a doctor had me tripping balls,
man.
Your Shit,
right?
Yeah.
Get yourself some kettlebells.
Get yourself some battle ropes.
Become fucking savage.
The savage that you really want to be deep inside the little cave man body.
Uh,
use a code name Brogan and save 10% off supplements and a,
I will see you guys later tonight.
One more podcast tonight.
Late night,
10:00 PM on the West Coast with Duncan Trussell doing it.
Big Peg.
I love you.
Dirty bitches.
We're off next week though.
Next week I'm on vacation,
so go fuck yourself.
Okay.
See you soon.
Bye.
[inaudible] love you guys.
Yeah.